welcome back to the stronger by science
podcast it's been a very long wait
but we are finally back for a new season
of real
hard-hitting evidence-based scientific
fitness content uh this is the one and
only official stronger by science
podcast uh there were some fireside
chats in recent weeks
um
historically they've been our worst
rated shows we've gotten a lot of
negative feedback this little string was
no exception a lot of people saying
that they generally just lacked the
structure and direction that you would
expect from a well-hosted show but i'm
glad to say that i'm back as the special
temporary primary host for this season
of the show uh but greg will be joining
me as uh the permanent guest co-host for
now at this point in time so greg thank
you for joining me for another season
yeah thanks for having me back on as far
as the fireside chats go you know i i
understand that when it comes to media
some people just like
uh things to be spoon fed to them
they're kind of they're kind of looking
for lowest common denominator type
content like there's a reason big bang
theory was the number one show in
america for a long time and not everyone
appreciates more niche indie artistic
projects like the like the fireside chat
series but you know it's it's a big
world takes all types and uh yeah it's
it's good to be back
yeah i think sometimes people think that
they're tapping into some kind of niche
you know kind of content area and a lot
of times it just falls flat you know it
just doesn't have the juice that you
would expect uh but nonetheless we're
back to get to uh back to the science
you know back back to what people are
here for so
uh as always if you like the show be
sure to like rate and subscribe wherever
you get it uh if you want to get more
information about the newest research in
exercise and nutrition be sure to join
our newsletter by going to
strongerbyscience.com
newsletter if you're looking for a
one-on-one virtual coach be sure to
check out strongerbyscience.com
coaching we've got a very talented team
of coaches if you want to get a little
discount on your dietary supplements
head over to bulksupplements.com and use
our discount code the code is sbs pod
and that will get you a five percent
discount off of your entire order uh of
course you could further support us by
checking out the mass research review
which is published every single month or
you could check out macro factor which
is the diet app that we co-developed and
it does come with a free trial so you
have an opportunity to test it out and
see if you like it before you make any
kind of financial commitment to it
um we've got two really nice segments
planned for today's episode but before
we get into that we have some
announcements and then uh just kind of a
fun little news article that i came
across for a brief discussion but first
um we're back for a new season i have
notes here because i'm what you would
call
a very stupid person and i would not
remember this without notes uh we are
going to have a slight change coming up
in the recording schedule uh we didn't
want to just like
blindside people with it and pull the
rug out and leave people um you know
wondering where the podcast is we
currently release episodes on thursday
and we put up you know the audio we put
up the full youtube video all that stuff
we're going to change some things behind
the scenes which is going to impact when
episodes come out and exactly how they
come out so
at some point in the near future there's
going to be a shift in the release
schedule we're still going to be
recording every single week from now for
the foreseeable future but there is
going to be a week in the near future
where it seems like the episode is
coming late and that's because we're
switching from a
very straightforward thursday release to
a different kind of release pattern so
the full episode basically the way it's
going to happen is moving forward on
wednesdays we are going to release one
of our segments on our youtube channel
as a standalone video and what we're
trying to do is put some of these
shorter segments out because
some people very understandably say hey
we love your show it's some of the best
content i've ever seen in really any
genre of content but the episodes are
long you know if you could kind of give
me the bite-sized clips it'd be helpful
so on wednesday we're going to release a
segment on youtube
and we're going to be including more
visual elements kind of showing images
and stuff on the screen on friday we're
going to release another segment on
youtube and then that following monday
is when you're going to get the full
podcast episode wherever you get
podcasts and also the full episode will
be uploaded to youtube so that's the
approach we're going to be taking and
like i said
there's going to be one week there where
there's kind of a a bit of a a gap where
you have to wait a little bit longer for
the full episode we tried to petition to
make some very straightforward changes
to the gregorian calendar and i think we
made a good pitch given that you are one
of the greg's and there aren't that many
we thought we might have some special
claim to that type of authority
um but it really got nowhere uh you know
our appeals didn't really go through so
instead of changing the entire gregorian
calendar we've just decided to have a
slightly slower release one week
right yes sir
okay so with that out of the way um
i came across
a
uh
an article here i'm gonna link it in the
show notes it was on science.org
and it was about some pretty cool
legislation that came out uh or i don't
know if it's legislation it was kind of
a
a government decision that that was uh
dictated and released but basically uh
the the united states government the
executive branch put out a statement
indicating that they're going to be
requiring immediate public access to all
u.s funded research papers by 2025. now
in terms of the implement implementation
details i don't know him okay but this
is a nice
if nothing else a nice gesture a move
toward a more open science world where
uh people who
are interested in research will have
greater access to that research without
it being uh hidden behind pay walls so
it's kind of a longer term goal like i
said the the
the announcement indicated that by 2025
the us government is going to say hey if
we funded the research it's got to be
open access um there's going to be a lot
of ways and i'll note that's that's not
like a a new and radical move right um i
believe the eu did something similar in
2018 and as of like 2020 2021
thereabouts uh publicly funded research
by bodies in the eu
uh have to be publicly available uh on
print
so really it's uh you know this isn't a
a brand new move in this area it's just
the the us joining what the eu is
already doing as as far as i'm aware
yeah but but it's really nice because
you know in many cases those articles
would be kept behind a pay wall for
extended periods of time
and so they're trying to make sure that
people have access to that information
sooner rather than later which is a
really positive thing but of course it
wouldn't be stronger by science without
a little bit of snark
in reading this article i found some
very hilarious clip like little quotes
that i had to comment on
uh
so
one of the things it said uh many
commercial publishers and non-profit
nonprofit scientific societies have long
fought to maintain a one-year embargo
basically keeping stuff behind a paywall
for at least a year
uh saying that it's critical to
protecting subscription revenues that
cover editing and production costs and
fund society activities uh
to me
my opinion is that that's totally
[ __ ] uh the the editing and
production costs are very very tiny um
the
and the argument like well this is bad
because it hurts our publishing revenue
uh i understand why that would be
important to a for-profit publisher but
for everybody else uh it seems more like
a a hindrance to disseminating research
than anything else so i understand why
the people who are uh
keeping the stuff behind pay walls
really like pay walls but uh to act like
that some kind of act for the the common
good is a bit of a stretch
yeah i mean also like
the
the grift itself is incredible because
essentially like what what costs money
in this process uh you need funds to
actually like buy equipment pay subjects
you know buy uh
like certain chemicals you'll need for
analyses whatever um
so if it's publicly funded research like
that's being paid for by tax dollars
especially if the research is being done
at like an r1 public institution you
know those salaries are getting paid uh
like there are federal subsidies and
also like state tax dollars are going to
like cover the salaries of everyone
doing the research and then what does
the journal do uh like what uh capital
inputs do they have in the process
basically none like they've got a copy
editor and a web manager that just
uploads the pdf to a website and that's
about it um and then you know they they
reap all of the profits from the system
so you know all of like
probably 98 of the costs are being
covered by the public already uh so it's
it's uh you know public input and then
in terms of extracting value from the
system it's all just like private
companies just just doing rent seeking
behavior to
to suck all of that up um so yeah like
it doesn't it never made sense for it to
be paywalled in the first place and then
two this isn't going to affect their
business models because
like a
lot of the research is still privately
funded and so it wouldn't be subject
these new regulations
and like the the journals make virtually
100
of their income from
like university library subscriptions to
their journals which they kind of bundle
and you know sell access to
you know if you're a publisher with 300
journals you kind of bundle that all
together and a library pays subscription
access to all of those a minority of the
studies in across all of those journals
will be publicly funded so
you know if you're if you're a school
you basically have to pay for for access
like you have to buy these subscriptions
because the scientists doing research at
your institution they need to be able to
keep up with what's going on in their
field and so you know essentially like
you know 70 percent of the work in a
field may have been paywalled before and
now like
64 will still be paywalled and those
those schools will still have to pay for
access to all of the same journals as
before so you know if if it affects the
publishers bottom lines at all it will
be a pretty minimal effect like i said
the eu put in similar regulations uh a
few years ago
and
the profits for all of these scientific
publishers has still been increasing so
yeah they're just crying over spilt milk
yeah it's also kind of funny because
it's it's almost like hey
you know
if you guys do this how are we going to
ensure the absolute highest quality copy
editing and it's like dude we've read
enough journals to say like
dude the number of times you run into a
figure that is so poorly made that it's
uninterpretable the number of times you
see just blatant errors where it's like
hey
is this just the same paragraph pasted
twice like
if they're paying a like if if they're
putting a substantial amount of money
and effort into that it's it's not even
doing that well on the copy editing
front yeah and then for everything else
all of the really labor-intensive
resource-intensive stuff is totally
outsourced for free yeah you know so
it's difficult for me to get too upset
on behalf of the publishers here
uh another quote that i found really
hilarious uh i'm not gonna say like call
out the person by name with the quote
but they were talking to someone who was
speaking kind of like on behalf of
publishers
and uh it said they support a transition
to immediate public access but they
criticize the new policy and the quote
was
we would have preferred to chart our own
course to open access
without a government mandate
uh now people have been clamoring about
the insane structure of this industry
for
a very long time
and to me this kind of sounds like
someone who's been evading their taxes
for many years
and has gotten like 25 stern letters in
the mail saying like
dude you have to pay your taxes and it
just ignores all of them then gets
arrested for tax evasion i was like dude
that's so aggressive i i really wish you
would have let me sort this out on my
own because i i very much planned on
promptly repaying all that yeah it's
like
you've had a million chances to actually
be proactive here
so yeah the mandate's happening yeah so
yeah that article i found it to be a bit
funny but also it's a really promising
it's not going to completely like you
said change the face of academic
publishing unfortunately
but it is a step toward a better
direction yeah right so so ultimately
good stuff and
you know yielded some some nice fun
quotes in the process
i agree you look like you're about to
say something very insightful uh yeah so
i i just wanted to comment slightly more
on like the the business model of
publishing because i i think like people
who
haven't
even like dipped their toes in academia
or or thought about this too much
might hear this and be like oh like this
this seems bad like these these people
are
uh excited about further regulations of
private business
and like i i can understand that to some
extent from like an ideological
perspective but i think it makes the
most sense to think of academic
publishing
like a utility
but like a
a utility
that is mostly unregulated so you know
just imagine
you live in a place where there's a
single electricity provider um
and let's say you live in the south and
you've got to pay for air conditioning
otherwise where you live is essentially
uninhabitable like noah no one lived in
the south before air conditioning
existed yeah for good reason um
so you know like you
you don't strictly have to pay for it
but like you basically have to yeah and
the way that like electricity utilities
are regulated is
um you know saying that they can charge
enough to make a profit but it's like
somewhat constrained
essentially like
we have duke energy here and they can't
just say like oh yeah we're going to
increase our rates eight-fold even
though our calls haven't increased and
you have to pay for it so like whatever
[ __ ] you um but that that's like
basically how publishing works because
the journals themselves and the content
in the journals is essentially a utility
like it's it's the raw materials that
scientists need to have access to to
keep up with their field know what's
going on understand what the next steps
are when they're generating hypotheses
designing studies like they need access
to that
but you know the the
amounts that journals can charge
is completely unregulated so they they
kind of have
academic institutions in a vice grip
where they can't essentially say
we can charge whatever we want for
access to our journals and you have to
pay it because if you don't like
no good researcher is gonna want to come
to your school because they either won't
have access to the stuff going on in
their field or
they'll have to like pay out of pocket
just to access all of the journals that
publish stuff in their field which if
you're subscribing one journal at a time
for an individual like that that would
be several thousand dollars a year yeah
um so like schools effectively are
forced to pay um
and so yeah it's it's like a utility
in that in that manner
except like they're holding all the
cards so yeah you know this this slight
tweak and policy to make a little bit
more uh research publicly available
right away as soon as it's published
when it's being funded by public funds
no less um
you know in terms of the extent to which
i think publishing should be regulated
this is
this is such a
tiny step in the right direction like
it's it's not going to blow up their
spot um
yeah that's yeah and what i wanted to
say along those lines i mean the
argument for
uh widely available access uh to that
research is
is very straightforward uh it's not like
asking for a handout it's like
you know you think about the work that
gets done on publicly funded grants
by researchers
and their staff at publicly funded
universities
uh you know the people that are gaining
access to this research have already
paid for it yeah
and what the publishers would prefer
is that the public funds the materials
for the study the public funds the staff
for the study the public funds the
infrastructure for the university and
then the publicly funded libraries at
those universities have to buy the
research again yeah and then only people
who are currently affiliated with those
institutions actually can access it yeah
and so everyone else is like i funded
this research in like seven different
ways yeah nice they're playing get it
they're paying for one thing three times
that they still don't have access to
exactly yeah so yeah this is not like
some radical
give everything free to everybody it's
like dude i bought this three times yeah
can i see it yeah
pub publishing is such a grift yeah
whatever all right so now let's move on
to one of our two uh more
science-focused segments here uh we're
gonna start out with your segment greg
which is on stretching and calf growth
yes yes um
all right so i
i would have maybe liked a different
lead-in which is totally fine i was
going to start with a with a rhetorical
question in an attempt to make this
somewhat more conversational sure i was
going to say eric
what what muscle group or muscle groups
do people complain about the most saying
odds it's so hard to grow this
particular muscle group certainly calves
all right i would say the same thing so
isn't it interesting that maybe we have
one weird trick for massive calf growth
uh not really but um
yeah i'm talking about a study that was
published recently from warnicky and
colleagues the title is
influence of long-lasting static
stretching on maximal strength muscle
thickness and flexibility and for this
segment i'm only going to be talking
about the the muscle thickness bit um
you know i i think most people realize
that stretching a muscle improves
flexibility over time
not really worth getting into but the
the hypertrophy findings were were
pretty interesting
um
and we we posted about this study on the
stronger by science instagram a couple
weeks ago uh check out the instagram if
you haven't already
and uh
the the post got a lot of engagement and
also
a lot of questions
um suggesting that i think some people
didn't fully understand
why we were why we were talking about
this study in the first place um
so i i wanted to do this segment for the
podcast both just to
talk through the study and the results
of the study more but also i think it's
a very useful study
for
helping us learn learn more about the
process
of accruing scientific knowledge over
time because studies don't just exist in
a vacuum you know and
i think most
most consumers of information are
interested in science for the purpose of
giving answers of how should i train to
maximize gains but generally there's
a fairly long process
getting you to that point of trying to
figure out not just works best like not
just what works best but why it works
better than other alternatives like
understanding mechanisms which can then
be used to guide future research to
actually optimize training um so reading
between the lines were people basically
saying like that this is
this has low ecological validity like
it's not directly applicable well they
were basically saying like oh well
resistance training has to be more
effective than stretching for calf
growth so like why should i care in the
first place okay yeah
uh
so yeah let's um let's kind of trace
trace the history that brings us to this
study um to discuss why it's important
so uh just as a background
we've known for a long time that
training through a full range of motion
uh tends to cause more muscle growth
than training through a partial range of
motion
the classic study that people tend to
cite to to support this point is by
bloomquist and colleagues uh but there
there have been plenty more studies that
that have been published in the
intervening years uh the the bloomqua
study was from either 2011 or 2013 i
believe and in that study they compared
the effects of
basically quarter squats so squatting to
about 60 degrees of knee flexion versus
parallel squats so squatting to about
120 degrees of knee flexion
uh
so you you can see if you're watching
this on youtube what those ranges of
motion looked like in in the graphic
that we're going to put on screen
uh so
cool image too it looks like the
person's wearing like one of those
spiderman suits it is yeah it looks like
a skeleton in a mocap suit so high-tech
and spooky cool um
so you know subjects trained through
these two different ranges of motion for
12 weeks following the same training
program and basically they found that
the the group doing parallel squats
experienced way more quad growth than
the group doing shallow squats uh and
also if you're watching on youtube we'll
we'll flash these results up here but
you know for for the most part they
measured um
they measured quadriceps cross-sectional
area so so just cross-sectional area of
all of the muscle mass on the front of
the thigh
at uh six different points so
some some more proximal points closer to
the hip down to more distal points
closer to the knee and what you saw was
at basically all points uh the the deep
squat group uh experienced increases in
muscle cross-sectional area of like four
to seven percent in that pretty tight
range
the shallow squat group did see some
pretty decent hypertrophy at just the
more proximal regions uh so closer to
the hip um
but then for for the distal regions they
saw no changes in quad size or even
slight decreases so
overall the the deep squat group uh just
saw way better quad gains than the
shallow squat group
however
uh with with a type of study like that
it's difficult to isolate variables
because you could say oh hey
uh you know maybe the difference we're
seeing here
is due to the fact that the total range
of motion
was different so the deep squat group
was training through twice as much total
knee flexion as the shallow squat group
or you could say it's because the mu the
muscle links being trained were
different so not only was the range
total range of motion different
but the deep squat group
as they were going down they were
training the quads at longer muscle
lengths longer total muscle lengths than
the shallow squat group so
is it the muscle links that matter or is
it the total range of motion it's hard
to say
just from the bloom quest study and from
uh probably the first half dozen studies
that we're looking at this question
so uh more recently there have been a
few studies that help
disambiguate this a little bit further
so um
i i'm going to talk about a study from
pedrosa and colleagues that will be
linked in the show notes but there there
have been
some some studies illustrating a similar
point by sato and colleagues and uh
mayo and colleagues maeo i believe
um but yeah the the study by pedroso was
the first that i think really helps
disambiguate that effect is it the
muscle links being trained or is it the
total range of motion
so
in in the study by pedrosa uh there were
five groups uh one of the groups and all
of them were training knee extensions
over 12 weeks
one of the groups trained through a full
range of motion which they defined as
from 100 degrees of knee flexion to 30
degrees of knee flexion so they
basically had a custom built knee
extension machine rigged up where
subjects didn't lock out all the way at
the top i think to kind of maintain
muscle tension in all of the groups not
totally sure but basically 100 to 30
degrees of knee flexion was full range
of motion in this group
then they had an initial range of motion
group which only trained from 100 to 65
degrees of knee flexion so only training
at relatively long muscle lengths so not
doing the top part of the range of
motion then they had a final range of
motion group which only trained from 65
to 30 degrees of knee flexion so same
total range of motion as the initial
range of motion group 35 degrees of
total uh knee knee flexion range of
motion um
but they were only training at short
muscle links then there was a varied
range of motion group where essentially
they would do half of their training
with partials at long muscle lengths and
half of their training with partials at
short muscle lengths
and a control group
and there there were a lot of outcomes
in this study so there were five groups
they looked at two different muscles
both the vastus lateralis and rectus
femoris and they also assessed uh muscle
cross-sectional area at four different
points along the thighs
so you know there there are
what like somewhere around 120 discrete
uh comparisons you could make in this
study but overall the the trend was
pretty clear
um
all of the groups that trained at long
muscle lengths so the initial range of
motion group the varied range of motion
group and the full range of motion group
uh all experienced more quad growth than
the final range of motion group that was
only training in short muscle links and
they all did better than the control
group which is what you should expect
um
but this strongly suggests that the
important factor with full range of
motion outperforming partial range of
motion
isn't the range of motion per se
it's the fact that when compared to kind
of the traditional approach of partial
range of motion training full range of
motion training involves training at
long muscle links and that seems to be
the important part because when you do
partial range of motion training at long
muscle links that seems to be
just as effective for hypertrophy as
full range of motion training uh or if
anything maybe slightly more so like
uh that and that's somewhat ambiguous um
but at minimum it seems like partial
range of motion training at long muscle
links is at least as effective as full
range of motion training which suggests
range of motion per se doesn't matter
all that much but there's something
important about training at long muscle
links for promoting hypertrophy
so then the next question is
basically why like why is that so much
more effective
um
and now we're getting closer to where
the calf stretching study comes in so
a hypothesis that's been put forth to
potentially explain why training that
long muscle links is particularly
effective for hypertrophy
is the concept of stretch-mediated
hypertrophy which is essentially the
idea that a
active contractile stimulus when also
paired with a stretch stimulus uh leads
to more hypertrophy you know better
intramuscular signaling that would
lead downstream to hypertrophy
uh than
just that active contractile stimulus um
so that that's basically the idea of
stretch-mediated hypertrophy
and we've we've i think reached a point
in some segments of the fitness industry
where that's already accepted as fact
like uh part partial range of motion at
long muscle links is really effective
for hypertrophy and full range of motion
training is really effective for
hypertrophy because of stretch-mediated
hypertrophy
and we know that's the mechanism driving
it the thing is we're not there yet uh
that is still a hypothesis that hasn't
been fully proven
and
the the evidentiary basis for it like
there there's certainly a theoretical
argument you can make for it um you know
if you wanted to make an argument about
total tension on the muscle presupposing
that all hypertrophy just comes down to
mechanical tension and you look at maybe
increases in passive tension as muscle
lengths increase and you say oh well the
stretch media mediated hypertrophy
that's because at long muscle lengths
you can put more total tension on the
muscle bigger hypertrophy stimulus that
is
certainly a logical train of thought but
if you
are interested in approaching this from
an empirical perspective
like every discrete step in that train
of of
it hasn't been fully proven and
elucidated yet
so currently stretch media mediated
hypertrophy is
just a hypothesis
and it was a hypothesis on
somewhat tenuous ground from my
perspective and the reason for that is
most of the time not all of the time but
most of the time
when you have a stimulus you know is
effective for a particular outcome so in
this case you know resistance training
active muscular contractile tension we
know that's effective for hypertrophy uh
if you
do something else to augment that to
make it even more effective
generally the thing you're you're
augmenting it with
is also at least to some extent
effective for hypertrophy in its own
right so a good analogy here would be
protein intake so you can't just force
feed protein and get huge without
resistance training but we also know
that independent of resistance training
protein intake does do a lot of nice
things related to muscle protein balance
so you know without a resistance
training stimulus if you eat more
protein
you might lose muscle a little bit
slower without a training stimulus uh
and you know i'm comparing like kind of
normal to super low protein intakes
there uh we know that that
mechanistically um consuming enough
leucine in a meal will trigger muscle
protein synthesis like there there are
a lot of those little variables like
that where you can look at protein and
isolation and be like oh this should do
some nice things for muscle itself so
then when you pair adequate protein
intake with a resistance training
stimulus that protein augments the
resistance training response to give you
better results than you would see
otherwise and so that that's what you
tend to see for things that that might
augment training responses
and the thing with stretching is there
wasn't great evidence that it did
independently do much for hypertrophy
outcomes uh at least in humans and with
uh any sort of reasonable stimulus so
there there were some chronic stretch
studies in birds and cats and rodents
back in the 80s and 90s which basically
found like if you put birds wings under
a weighted stretch for weeks at a time
it caused
ridiculous amounts of hypertrophy and
muscle hyperplasia um
but you know like one were not birds and
two
that hadn't been independently observed
in humans and so if you if you want
evidence like indirect evidence for the
concept of stretch-mediated hypertrophy
it sure would be nice to have human
evidence
showing that stretching itself uh posed
a hypertrophy stimulus to the muscle
um
and there had been
some prior suggestions that stretching
per se could result in hypertrophy so
the study there that people would most
commonly cite was by simpson and
colleagues published i think in like
2015 2016
where
subjects
had one leg that they stretched for six
weeks one leg that they didn't stretch
for six weeks and the stretch was a
loaded calf stretch on a leg press
machine that they would hold for three
minutes five days per week so three
minutes per day five days per week for
six weeks uh loaded calf stretching
and that study did report that uh
that that stretching intervention led to
hypertrophy
but uh we'll
again if you're if you're watching this
on youtube we'll flash the results up on
the screen comparing the stretched and
non-stretched legs
and really it's not a slam dunk case so
the difference in
uh
in calf thickness
in the stretched and unstretched legs
was a little bit less than one
centimeter at baseline
and was ever so slightly more than one
centimeter after the six-week
intervention
um
which the the authors reported was a
statistically significant result p of
0.04 barely significant it was the type
of thing where
uh depending on your perspective you
could look at the study and be like okay
this is some amount of confirmation that
stretching is an independent hypertrophy
stimulus
but if you wanted to be more skeptical
you could look at it and be like okay
like i i want to see more like this this
isn't
super convincing stuff quick
interjection here um
to prove that i'm paying attention you
you set a difference of one centimeter
should that be a millimeter oh yeah yeah
point one centimeter yeah okay yeah my
bad um
so yeah it was um
essentially there was
a little bit of prior evidence that a
stretching intervention
might lead to hypertrophy in humans but
it was
i i personally wanted to see more right
um so the the study i'm talking about
here from warnicky uh was
what i would term a
um
a proof of concept study so essentially
with a proof of concept study what
you're trying to do
is you think that an effect exists
and you try to stack the deck
in your favor to
greatly increase the odds of you
actually observing that effect so a
great example of kind of a whole area of
research where there are a lot of proof
of concept studies is studies that are
interested in looking at different
recovery modalities and the way those
studies tend to work is they put people
through
a muscle damage protocol that far
exceeds anything anyone would ever do in
practice so you know it might involve
75 maximal eccentric reps for a
particular muscle group which
if you've never done that before that's
i think almost an eighth amendment
violation like it's it's rough you're
gonna be [ __ ] up from that
um
but you know it's causing
so much soreness so much muscle damage
that if whatever recovery modality
you're interested in
if it will improve recovery that is the
type of situation where there's so much
to recover from that you will be able to
observe that effect if you just kind of
put people through a more quote unquote
normal resistance training stimulus
where people would just recover in 48
hours just fine anyways
you know even if the thing you're
studying was very effective you might
not be able to observe that effect
because you hadn't adequately stacked
the deck in your favor
so i i would call the the warnicky study
a proof of concept study
for the potential impact of stretching
on hypertrophy so the
the training intervention was more
intense
and longer lasting
than i think most people would do on
their own
so it was also a six-week intervention
like the simpsons study uh it involved
daily stretching lasting for one hour a
day
much like the simpsons study uh subjects
had one leg that was stretched one leg
that was unstretched uh so each each
subject served as their own control
and essentially there was a calf
stretching orthosis
an orthotic device that you would put
your foot in
and there were basically straps that you
could pull to pull your toes up pull
your ankle into
dorsiflexion
that's right yeah yeah i always forget
dorsiflexion plantarflexion so yeah you
could pull your toes up to pull your
ankle into dorsiflexion and essentially
lock it in for an hour
um
and subjects were instructed
on a one to ten pain scale to stretch to
the point of an eight and i doubt they
actually got there um
because like if if tin is
the most severe pain a human could be in
an eight is probably like a broken bone
um and i don't think they were actually
stretching to that intensity it was
probably more like a six i would guess
but anyway uh put yourself in a pretty
uncomfortable calf stretch and hold it
for a full hour and do that every day
for six weeks uh which like i said in a
proof of concept study that's that's
more stretching than i think most people
do for a particular muscle group but you
know
this is the type of study where if
stretching
can
cause an independent hypertrophy
response this is the type of study where
we would see it and if we do see
hypertrophy in a study like that that
confirms that a stretch stimulus
might be an independent hypertrophy
stimulus which would help make more
sense for why
stretch media stretch-mediated
hypertrophy might be a thing like it
helps put that concept on firmer
theoretical and evidentiary footing
and
essentially that's what they found
so over
those six weeks of stretching the
stretch legs experienced an increase in
uh calf muscle thickness of about 15
so that's a that's a pretty notable
increase compared to just two percent in
the control legs uh and also there was a
good a good population used for this
study so they weren't completely
untrained subjects they were quote
athletically active having performed two
or more training sessions per week in a
gym or a team sport continuously for the
previous six months so
you know it once again it's not like
the the type of thing where with
completely untrained folks ah you know
anything might be a hypertrophy stimulus
like we're we're seeing
uh
calf growth just from stretching in
folks who are at least like
recreationally trained um
so
overall i i think this is is pretty
promising
uh like i said the main takeaway of this
study i think is that it puts the idea
of stretch me mediated hypertrophy on
firmer theoretical and conceptual
footing uh and like i said kind of in
tracing
the progress of science in this area
over time we started with the
observation that full range of motion
training led to more growth than partial
range of motion training the next
question is why is that is it total
range of motion or is it the range of
motion being trained then more recently
we had studies saying hey it's probably
the range of motion being trained
the the fact that you're training
through long muscle links
that seems to be more important than
total range of motion per se
and then the next question is well why
is training that long muscle links
particularly effective
might it be this idea of
stretch-mediated mediated hypertrophy
well if it is it sure would be nice to
see that stretching per se
was an independent hypertrophy stimulus
which would help it make sense for why
it might augment regular resistance
training induced hypertrophy um so
essentially that's where we're at now
and then the next question is what can
we do with that uh
you know can we use this information to
make kind of normal resistance training
interventions more effective uh you know
and it could be that we're
a few years away from a breakthrough
where we find out hey maybe full range
of motion training is
you know certainly effective but maybe
partial range of motion training at long
muscle links is even more effective so
you know maybe maybe the bros were right
the idea of constant tension training
not locking out your reps
that they may have been on to something
like that may lead to more growth than
just kind of standard full range of
motion training uh we have yet to see
and fully confirm that but you know
that's sort of the next steps to take
after a study like this
and one thing i will note
is even though
i would term this uh a proof of concept
study
the the type of thing where most people
probably wouldn't do themselves you
could actually do this so if you're
really struggling with calf growth and
maybe you're insecure about your small
calves
or you know if you just want to
you know maybe maybe do omar esof a
solid send this to him um
this is the type of thing where you you
could actually implement this
intervention so they were just
stretching one calf you could do this
with both just get some orthoses
and if you're sitting for an hour a day
at work
playing video games watching tv
you could just put your foot in that
orthosis get it in a stretch and just
chill out for an hour um
i don't know how many people will want
to do that but that this is
theoretically a practical intervention
someone could try to boost their calf
growth but but for the most part it is
mainly a proof of concept study
um
so yeah like that's
that's mostly what i wanted to talk
about
the the point that i wanted to make
clear um
is that by talking about this study on
the podcast posting about it on
instagram um i'm certainly not saying
that stretching is more effective than
lifting for muscle growth and i'm not
saying that you should
try
like just stop training your calves and
only stretch them to promote muscle
growth that's certainly not what they're
saying uh this is more about
trying to figure out why something works
and in this case trying to figure out
precisely why full range of motion
training tends to be more effective than
short muscle length partials
why partials at long muscle links seem
to be particularly effective uh for
muscle growth whether the whole concept
of stretch me mediated hypertrophy holds
water in the first place you know it
very well could be
that training at longer muscle links
does lead to more hypertrophy due to
some mechanism other than the stretch
stimulus like that's certainly still on
the table so this study
helps helps confirm that the stretch
stimulus very well could be augmenting
the normal kind of resistance training
hypertrophy response
and also i'll note that
this is also the type of study that
could potentially be useful
for clinical populations so
one of the issues if someone say
comes down with a really bad disease
gets hurt really bad and they're on bed
rest for a few weeks one of the issues
you run into with recovery there
is if you're on bed rest and you can't
move around at all people just
hemorrhage muscle and strength to the
tune of losing strength
at a at a clip of about one percent per
day
and muscle size at about half a percent
per day so
you know if you're on bed rest for a
month uh
you you're in rough shape when you come
back and so just for
getting getting back up and
reconditioning yourself just for
day-to-day life like that
that uh can cause issues like just the
muscle and strength loss
and so if it could be that just
intensely stretching a muscle for an
hour a day
if that's effective not even as a
hypertrophy stimulus but just for
maintenance of muscle mass in those
sorts of situations um you know it could
be a
an efficacious intervention that that
people could do in situations where they
can't resistance train um so it's also
useful from that perspective but yeah
for for the most part i i wanted to talk
about this to
mainly just trace the the story of
scientific discovery because most people
really do just want to be told okay well
that's cool and all but like how do i
train to get [ __ ] huge and strong and
jacked but ultimately this is the stuff
leading to that stuff um there's
almost always this process of
progressive discovery you make an
observation
you try to explain that observation
and then the next answer leads to
another set of questions um and you know
it is that that incremental uh process
and
since uh since range of motion and the
concept of stretch me mediated
hypertrophy are i think kind of hot in
the fitness industry right now
i think it's work i thought it was worth
kind of taking a step back and tracing
how we got here and
how you might go about answering
questions to
more fully elucidate
why these things seem to work
yeah this brought up a lot of flashbacks
for me um
the
worst feedback the most criticism i've
ever gotten for an instagram post
was also a kind of proof of concept
study
and
i swore that day if if i ever post again
about a proof of concept study i'm going
to have a disclaimer at the beginning
middle and end of the post uh because i
i think i caught a lot of it yeah it was
like a caffeine post and people were
like
eric you are the stupidest person i've
ever met
who would take nine milligrams per
kilogram of caffeine and it's like well
if you want to see how caffeine works
that's one way to do it yeah you know
it's the same kind of thing with this
like
the utility extends far beyond the
experimental design just from the uh the
proof of concept but yeah if you want to
see
hey can stretching a calf grow it like
yeah throw them in the boot for an hour
and see what happens yeah you know so
it's it's very helpful to see why things
like this are useful even if you're not
saying hey
go home and replicate this uh this
experimental protocol in its entirety
absolutely
all right good stuff ready to move on
yes sir
so
greg let's talk a little bit about
reverse dieting
oh my favorite
so
a quick question what does reverse
dieting do
oh man
um
so
you know i think it i think it's good
for uh reversing metabolic damage for
building up my metabolic capacity
helping me maintain weight on a higher
total calorie intake
helping me
maintain a higher calorie intake the
next time i cut so i can get leaner
easier stay leaner longer without much
of an issue um
those are all of the things that i've
been led to believe that it does
and i will be very disappointed if it it
turns out that maybe it doesn't do some
of those things
yeah so with those claims uh of the
volumes of research supporting all of
them do you recall a single study
showing anything in that general
ballpark you know this isn't my area
this isn't the type of research that i
personally keep up to date with but due
to the
volume of claims being made about it and
the the confidence behind the claims
being made about it
i have to assume
that there is a lot of high quality very
strong data supporting it
that would be i'll also be very
disappointed if i find out that that's
not the case yeah that's a reasonable
assumption but
in this segment we're going to dig into
it a little bit okay so we're going to
talk about reverse dieting we're going
to talk about
a lot of the claims that are made about
it and digging into the evidence which
um
doesn't
the evidence is far less exciting than a
lot of the claims and hype surrounding
reverse dieting so we're going to dig
into the details here but you know
before i get into it i want to kind of
explain the backdrop here the history a
little bit so
since about 2013
i have been chewing on a general set of
related topics in my research in my blog
posts uh and just in my own life right
so one of the first things
that got me interested in these topics
was my own experiences as an athlete and
as a coach
as a two-sport professional athlete much
like bo jackson
so the general set of topics is
metabolic adaptation
weight regain after diets and both
short-term and long-term weight
regulation uh and it's not hard to
figure out how i got there i used to be
a wrestler transitioned into natural
bodybuilding and there's this psych you
know the cyclical process
by which you get very very lean for a
competition you regain weight you get
very very lean again and there are so
many physiological
adaptations and perturbations that occur
throughout that series of changes so
um
that's what got me into this in 2013 the
first time i ever published about this
set of concepts was 2014
uh in the peer-reviewed literature
and to the best of my knowledge
one of my papers was the first to
actually use the term reverse dieting in
the peer-reviewed literature so this is
a topic i've been following closely
since that paper was that paper was
published in 2014 was but was being
written back in 2013.
so i've been keeping my ear to the
ground
do you think
i mean just for for the listeners the
viewers uh do you think that that might
potentially be a source of bias where
you know you you might stand to benefit
from
all of this research you're about to
tell us about for how effective reverse
dieting is the fact that you are the the
first person to talk about it in the
literature
you know all of the support for reverse
dieting that you're about to tell us
about
kind of makes you look good in hindsight
so do you do you think you need to
disclose that conflict of interest
so yeah the conflict of interest is that
uh
you know
as a researcher
the only way for me to really benefit
from reverse dieting is by asserting oh
this definitely works right like i was
the first person that introduced this
into the literature i'm going to try to
take credit for that and that's going to
make me look like someone who was really
ahead of the curve in the research right
another potential conflict of interest
is hey we sell
a diet app we sell diet uh you know
products and content etc whatever the
case is uh we're in this industry right
so absolutely it would be beneficial for
us to say hey everyone's excited about
reverse dieting
let's make some cash let's profit off of
that excitement so
the conflict of interest argument uh
would on all accounts say eric
it benefits you to say that reverse
dieting absolutely lives up to the hype
and is very very worthwhile
um
as we're going to get into though
i am unable
to
to make any such evidence-based claim
that reverse dieting lives up to
basically any of the hype that surrounds
it wait what yeah i know so i need to
strap in exactly so you'll want to take
a seat this is spooky uh you know you
can leave the room if you need a minute
to to gather your thoughts uh and regain
your composure but i think it's best
that we probably just dive into the
evidence and kind of get into it so
um
you know in recent years reverse
dieting's become really really popular
uh in some areas of of the dieting world
and the fitness world
and what we want to do is basically
figure out
does it have supporting evidence is it
at least compatible with the most
relevant evidence available
and also are there potentially some more
parsimonious explanations
for the
positive anecdotes that we see on social
media there are a lot of people who say
i've done reverse dieting and it worked
great for me you should try it too but
you know one of the foundational
elements of science and by extension
evidence-based practice is
a general preference for parsimony right
so if there's a set of observations uh
you know we could say oh this is a
completely novel thing that's never been
discovered and we don't understand it
it's never been seen in the literature
yet but the literature will keep up
eventually or catch up yeah you know
we would much prefer to say oh i can
very much explain that set of
observations with a very tidy
explanation that's based on fairly
straightforward mathematical
explanations and stuff we've already
seen in the literature like that would
be preferable
if both lend an equal amount of support
for the topic right
so
uh
as you mentioned reverse dieting
often touted as a remedy for metabolic
adaptation and as a strategy to
facilitate easier and more sustainable
weight loss um could you uh just hit us
with a rough operational definition of
metabolic adaptation just for just for
people who who haven't listened to the
show before absolutely if this is your
first time listening to this show that
you've never heard of metabolic
adaptation
um so
the general idea is
we start dieting right we're restricting
energy we're in a calorie deficit or
negative energy balance which means that
our daily energy expenditure is greater
than our daily energy intake right so
that helps us start losing weight we're
in this energy deficit or we're in
negative energy balance and as we're
doing that we start to lose fat tissue
right and so metabolic adaptation
describes kind of an entire
cluster of adaptations that occur as a
person continues on that weight loss
trajectory so their total energy
expenditure goes down which would be
expected when you go from being a larger
person to a smaller person
you will burn fewer calories on a daily
basis uh with no adaptation required you
just have less tissue yeah if there's 20
percent less of me it takes 20 percent
less energy to to locomote myself around
the world right so so we expect that
energy expenditure should go down to
some extent but metabolic
adaptation describes uh an adaptive
reduction in energy expenditure so
energy expenditure goes down more than
we should have predicted based on the
loss of tissue
and what's really happening is it's kind
of like putting your phone on low
battery mode right where you basically
tell your phone like hey i haven't
charged you in a while resources are
tight so all the extra stuff you
normally do in the background let's try
to get as efficient as possible and
minimize energy usage right so that's in
a very simplistic sense what's going on
we're conserving energy to essentially
try to prevent further weight loss
because if we let weight loss go on
forever with no friction at all
we call that starvation in the biology
business right so we have an interest in
trying to introduce some friction there
because our bodies can't tell that we're
getting ready for a bodybuilding show
they think we're starving to death yeah
you know and so the hypothalamus is a
key brain structure that is
orchestrating metabolic adaptation which
involves not just a reduction in energy
expenditure but a lot of the unpleasant
side effects that we associate with
dieting so if you look at the metabolic
adaptation literature there's clear
parallels to what we call relative
energy deficiency in sport or relative
energy deficiency and it's this whole
cluster of things that happens when when
energy availability gets low right so we
might have low libido we might see that
testosterone and thyroid hormone go down
we might might be more lethargic more
hungry
it's just this entire set of adaptations
that is all in response to acute and
chronic restriction of energy the
hypothalamus is dictating this
and
ultimately leptin is a key signal that
is telling the hypothalamus leptin being
a hormone
that's produced in fat cells leptin is
relaying the signal to the hypothalamus
energy is tight you need to shut some
things down
and very importantly there are two
things that cause pretty substantial
perturbations in leptin levels
number one would just be being in an
energy deficit so acute energy
restriction reduces leptin the second
thing is the loss of fat tissue so as
fat cells start to shrink over time they
produce less leptin so it's very clear
in all the the literature that being in
an energy deficit independently
contributes to metabolic adaptation and
this reduction in energy expenditure but
also the loss of fat tissue over the
long term also has an independent
contribution okay so that's critically
important
so the theory with reverse dieting
is that
basically
increasing your calories very
slowly and systematically and
methodically can reverse
metabolic adaptation and some of these
other symptoms of dieting so the idea is
if you just start slowly increasing your
calories
your body will say oh there's some more
energy here enough for me to turn off
low battery mode but not enough for me
to decide to store any fat in the
process or any appreciable amount of fat
in the process so a lot a lot of folks
use reverse dieting saying well i want
to get back to how i used to feel before
the diet i want to get back to what my
energy expenditure was before the diet
because it's gone down a lot but i don't
want to regain much if any of the weight
that was lost
um so so the idea then would be that
these slow calorie increases are going
to dramatically increase daily energy
expenditure they are going to be very
carefully matched to your total daily
energy expenditure as you go
such that you're able to ramp energy
expenditure up and stop feeling so
lethargic and get your hormone levels
back to normal
and you're doing all of this stuff
essentially in the absence of fat gain
or with extremely minimal fat regain
that's the theory behind it and so it
gives rise to a number of common claims
so people will say
it fixes a damaged metabolic rate
people will say that
you know that metabolic adaptation is
essentially making it almost impossible
for you to lose any more weight and you
need a reverse diet so that you can
become able again to even have the hope
of losing more weight in the future
right so there's a two-fold claim there
one is that metabolic adaptation which
is sometimes claimed as like starvation
mode or metabolic damage the first claim
is that that is
a completely insurmountable road block
to further weight loss or just
maintaining weight loss after your
diet's done the second part of the claim
is that this is actually reversed and
fixed by reverse dieting
along those lines you'll see claims that
reverse dieting will fix any of those
hormone changes that that occurred
during weight loss in addition to
ramping up metabolic rate in some cases
people will take this a step further and
not just say oh reverse dieting will get
you back to your original total daily
energy expenditure at this lower body
weight some people even say
forget about it whatever weight you're
at this is going to supercharge your
metabolic rate such that your energy
expenditure is higher than you've ever
experienced in the past like you are
going to tap into a physiological state
that you have not previously reached in
your life
um
and one of the biggest claims one of the
biggest selling points that you see
among reverse dieting proponents is
you're doing this to lay the foundation
for a better future
you are super charging and building up
your metabolic rate and energy
expenditure because that's going to make
your next diet easier or it's going to
make it way easier to sustain weight
loss in the long run
the idea being
you're going to you used to have to get
down to 1700 calories a day to
effectively diet now you're only going
to have to go down to 2100 calories a
day to effectively diet and you're going
to get just as lean in the same amount
of time that's usually how it goes
so
there's a lot of questions that come up
here in this segment i'm going to try to
concisely go through and answer those
questions based on actual scientific
evidence not just like theorizing and
anecdotes and stuff like that
before i get into it i want to
acknowledge what i'm trying to do here
is break down
a 60-page article
into like a 20-ish minute segment which
i'm sure i'll go long on so don't even
check the time stamps you're absolutely
gonna go long but i i think this will
still be
audio visual gold yeah so just take the
time you need yeah but but i do want to
acknowledge if if you're hearing this
and saying yeah that sounds like the
cliff notes but i want the real stuff
um we are going to have uh by the time
this episode airs
the article should be live over at
macrofactorapp.com
and like i said it's like 60 pages in
its current form and it's going to
provide all the references that you hear
in this segment and provide even more
detail
so if you're into that be sure to check
out the link in the show notes and if
you're wondering why the show notes
don't have like
38 studies referenced it's because i'm
going to link to the article and say
here's where they are okay
so some questions that i want to address
by looking at the evidence do metabolic
rates get damaged because damage is a
pretty serious word
damage
seems to imply to me that there is
effort required to fix
right so do metabolic rates get damaged
in a really substantial and persistent
way
do low metabolic rates play a major role
in preventing weight loss or promoting
weight regain
does reverse dieting actually resolve
the effects of metabolic
adaptation does reverse dieting
supercharge your metabolic rate
uh especially after a diet
does reverse dieting immediately after a
weight loss phase prevent weight regain
or facilitate a smoother transition into
what we would call a maintenance phase
where you're just maintaining the weight
loss that you achieved
does reverse dieting make your next
weight loss phase easier
and if reverse dieting doesn't fix
metabolic adaptation what should we
actually do about it so that kind of
sets the stage for what we're going to
talk about here uh and with that with
that out of the way uh let's dig into
some of the evidence here so the first
thing i want to address is metabolic
adaptation versus metabolic damage right
so metabolic adaptation based on all the
research that's been done is a temporary
state and if you want to know how to
reverse it it's extremely easy to do
that and there's ample evidence showing
metabolic adaptation being reversed uh
what it takes is twofold the first step
is getting out of an energy deficit so
going from negative energy balance to
either neutral or positive that that
eliminates the kind of immediate element
that's driving metabolic adaptation but
there is that second element
like i said metabolic adaptation is
being driven by an energy deficit and
a loss of fat mass so there's ample
evidence that metabolic adaptation is
very easily reversed and what it takes
is getting out of the energy deficit and
regaining the fat that was lost
and i know that that's not what a lot of
people want to hear
because you'd love to say well i wish
the first part would take care of all of
it but based on the evidence that
doesn't seem to be the way that it works
uh it definitely looks like there's i'm
going to show a figure here from a great
review paper by dulu who's done a lot of
really excellent work on weight regain
after weight loss and based on the
evidence available it's very clear that
uh
there there's there's really four things
going on with weight regain after a diet
so
if you go from negative energy balance
to neutral or positive you're going to
eliminate the non-specific part of
adaptive thermogenesis which is
which is in some ways anonymous with
metabolic adaptation it adaptive
thermogenesis is only looking at the
energy expenditure component of
metabolic adaptation so
what we see is that in the weight regain
process
getting out of a deficit immediately
influences energy expenditure it doesn't
fully restore it to baseline it just
moves it up a little bit to where it was
at the end of the diet right uh and then
there's clearly an impact where
regaining fat is going to be part of the
process for fully restoring energy
expenditure to its initial level but
there's also two other important
regulatory factors in in the weight
regain process
one pertains to energy partitioning
and what the research would indicate is
that until you get back up to a body fat
percentage that is kind of similar-ish
to where you started you are going to
preferentially regain fat
rather than muscle
so it's not like this perfectly linear
thing where you regain both at these
completely similar rates
usually what happens is you regain a lot
of fat mass early in the weight regain
process and then
lean mass starts to catch up much later
there's a preferential regain of fat at
the beginning
and another important thing is
hyperphagia which basically describes
this really excessive level of hunger
that we experience during especially
very aggressive dieting that hyperphagia
doesn't seem to really chill out until
you've regained all of the lean mass
that you lost during the diet right so
there's a very robust body of literature
telling us you know what is dictating
these things we experience during weight
loss and what it takes to restore them
and
uh quite frankly there's there's not a
lot of room in this literature to
suggest that reverse dieting offers you
a path out that doesn't involve you know
this process of restoring some fat mass
and ultimately regaining a a pretty
decent amount of weight both in the
forms of fat mass and fat free mass
right so metabolic adaptation just to
kind of put a bow on this part
definitely a temporary state with
various different drivers
and full restoration of total daily
energy total daily energy expenditure is
something that based on the evidence is
going to require uh some degree of fat
regain in the process so just to be
clear you're saying
people can lose weight
and they certainly can maintain weight
loss like we're we're not trying to play
into the myth of all diets fail everyone
always regains the weight they lose it's
just if you do lose a pretty substantial
amount of weight and fat mass you should
anticipate
over the pretty long term
at least some degree of reduction in in
metabolic rate and total daily energy
expenditure right yeah that would be
correct
um
now
that that leads me to an important point
though which is that you know we've
talked about some of these
drivers of metabolic adaptation and what
it takes to fully reverse all elements
of metabolic adaptation 100
but a really important question is
are we sure that we actually need to
fully avoid metabolic adaptation even if
it were possible or
completely reverse it you know
how impactful is metabolic adaptation
when it comes to weight loss and weight
regain
so i'm going to put some images on on
the the screen if you're following along
on youtube uh but there's been a really
a series of studies here so there's a
study by martins and colleagues where
they're looking at okay
uh
how much does metabolic adaptation
impact an individual's ability to
actually lose weight during an
intervention what they found is
participants lost about 14 kilograms on
average that's a substantial weight loss
that was like 13 of their body weight uh
the typical
uh metabolic adaptation as they
quantified it was about a 92 calorie
reduction per day
uh and what they found was
yes people who experienced more
metabolic adaptation did lose less
weight over the course of this
intervention uh but what they found was
an increase in metabolic adaptation of
50 calories a day was associated with a
lower weight loss of only half a
kilogram and so just purely based on the
numbers there
is very clear to see
that even the people who experience
pretty substantial metabolic adaptation
you would still look at this and say you
had a very successful weight loss diet
here you know and that
just to put that number in perspective
the 92 calories that that's
disproportionate reductions in resting
metabolic rate not total daily energy
correction right disproportionate
relative to predicted looking at resting
energy expenditure so the the
presumably the reductions in total daily
energy expenditure were probably larger
right yes yeah yeah
um but but what this is telling us is
using uh metabolic adaptation looking at
the resting metabolic rate component
basically just as a means of kind of
sorting okay who was really experiencing
it uh versus who wasn't you know that
that's really the the utility there
rather than quantifying the total impact
in terms of calories per day but what
they're able to see is just like the
folks who were experiencing more
metabolic adaptation in this study still
had very successful weight loss programs
it just it they just didn't lose quite
as much during during the the program
right so it's not like they hit a brick
wall they just had a little bit more
friction along the way
uh there's also a study a different
study by martins and colleagues
where they were looking at the time to
reach a weight loss goal and in this
particular cohort weight loss on average
was 12 and a half kilograms
average weight loss time was 155 days
again they found that folks who
experience more metabolic adaptation it
did take them a little longer to get to
their weight loss goal but for each 10
calorie increase in metabolic adaptation
kilocalories per day
the time to reach their weight loss goal
increased by a single day right so when
you're talking about that number and
you're looking at in this cohort average
metabolic adaptation was quantified as
46 calories per day again the people
experiencing metabolic adaptation were
still
you would you would look at their
progress and say you are succeeding here
you are doing great you might just need
a little bit of extra time to get to
where you're going yeah right it's like
even in an extreme case like
if if other people would need to diet
for three months
even with pretty extreme metabolic
adaptation like you should you should
still be able to get the job done in
four months yeah so so what these
studies are showing us is that with
metabolic adaptation even if you're
experiencing it uh much more than the
average individual you should still be
there's still a very clear path between
you and your goal it might just require
slightly greater reductions in calorie
intake or
alternatively just a slightly longer
dieting timeline
this is friction it's not an
insurmountable roadblock right
uh another study by martins and
colleagues this group has been doing a
ton of work in this area over the last
few years uh they they found that
metabolic adaptation was not a
substantial barrier when it comes to
long-term maintenance of weight loss so
they actually looked at over a
one to two year follow-up period
metabolic adaptation was found on
average after weight loss again about in
the 54 calorie per day range
but this didn't really correlate with
people's likelihood of regaining weight
over the next two years there are much
more important predictors of weight
regain
that really have nothing to do with
metabolic rate or metabolic adaptation
it usually comes down to are you
continuing to monitor your
health-related behaviors and your
weight-related behaviors are you
continuing to track your food keeping
your activity level up uh you know
continuing to monitor body weight so it
as it starts creeping up you can then
address it before it gets you know
starts to really accumulate uh so there
are much more impactful predictors of
weight regain than anything to do with
metabolic metabolic rate or metabolic
adaptation
and then there's also an interesting
study by father gill and colleagues they
were looking at metabolic adaptations
six years after the biggest loser
competition which
i resent almost everything about the
biggest loser competition it's
unsustainable it's it's not good uh but
one of the silver linings is that there
was good research done surrounding uh
the biggest loser uh competition which
if you're not familiar it was like a tv
show with this extremely aggressive
weight loss intervention um and yeah the
intervention
like i said i'm not really a huge fan of
how it was done and how it was portrayed
yeah as a television program but
nonetheless there was some good research
that came of it um what they found was
that after this 30-week intervention the
amount of metabolic adaptation that you
experienced and there was a tremendous
magnitude in the study because of how
extreme the intervention was
after the weight loss period that
metabolic adaptation
didn't really correlate much at all with
your likelihood of regaining weight
what they did find was that people who
still had metabolic adaptation present
at the six year follow-up were actually
the people who
very successfully prevented weight
regain so
right after the diet metabolic
adaptation was not predictive of future
weight regain
at the follow-up period metabolic
adaptation was essentially a marker of
success for reducing weight regain
because if you regain the weight the
metabolic adaptation goes away as we've
already kind of covered uh so
what this research shows us you know and
there's actually even a better study i
would say there's a study by rimbach and
colleagues that was published just this
year as part of that huge doubly labeled
water database and we've been talking
about they've been cranking out really
high impact papers from that uh just in
terms of their utility was that the same
database that the the poncer
study about uh metabolic rates across
the lifespan where where that came from
yes okay yeah so
that database and the projects
surrounding it
have really helped clarify a lot of
things about metabolism and energy
expenditure and there was one recent
paper that came out this year and they
were basically interested in figuring
out like is low total daily energy
expenditure
a risk factor for weight gain
and similarly is high you know total
daily energy expenditure is this
actually protective against future
weight gain like what is looking at
someone's energy expenditure tell us
about their current body composition in
terms of predictive utility and what is
likely to happen in future weeks um and
what they found using gold standard
measurement techniques is that
essentially looking at someone's total
daily energy expenditure now
doesn't really tell you a ton about what
their body composition is likely to be
and
looking at how their total daily energy
expenditure changes over time doesn't
really tell you much about
you know
how how their body composition is going
to change and actually what they found
some of their analyses were basically
null findings and said yeah energy
expenditure doesn't give us a lot of
actionable information here the the only
correlations they found were actually
the opposite of what reverse dieting
would imply
so looking at
uh adjusted values for total daily
energy expenditure they found that
higher and like increasing values for
this adjusted total daily energy energy
expenditure value was actually
correlated with weight gain over the
time frame studied so what they i'll
read the quote here what they concluded
this
suggests that low energy expenditure
total daily energy expenditure is not a
risk factor for
uh
and high total daily energy expenditure
is not protective against weight or body
fat gain body fat gain over the time
intervals tested so basically this idea
that you need to reverse diet so that
you have this high energy expenditure
that you know induces future weight loss
or prevents weight regain after dieting
it doesn't seem to be compatible with
what we're seeing here and even just the
the purpose statement of well you need
reverse dieting because metabolic
adaptation just slams the brakes on your
weight loss
again
we're not really seeing those types of
claims supported by the literature yeah
i think that um
i think one thing that may be helpful
just to like talk about and clarify
is that
i think it's i think it's very easy and
tempting
to
test theoretical counter factuals about
yourself that did not in fact occur
and so by that i mean
um
so like like personally i have a
relatively low
rate of total daily energy expenditure
relative to both my size and activity
levels um like i'm eating
like a little under 2 000 calories per
day to lose weight very gradually and
i'm i'm like low to 20s and relatively
active
people hear that and they're like
that's that's crazy like that seems way
lower than it should be
and it might be easy for me to look at
that
and say man if i had a higher rate of
total daily energy expenditure it would
be a lot easier for me to lose weight
but the thing is
like
i don't know that uh and also like a lot
of the difficulty comes from
like
how how the the hunger cues you have and
how you respond to them yeah uh and
people will hear like people who are
smaller than me will hear oh you're
under 2 000 calories a day at your size
man if i had to go that low i would be
super hungry all the time but the thing
is like i'm not like i i feel generally
fine because to some degree to some
degree like hunger responses are
kind of tuned to how much energy you're
actually expending yeah and so if i was
burning 500 more calories per day and
eating 500 more calories per day um
if i look at that
assuming that my
feelings consuming 2 500 calories per
day in that situation would be the same
as they currently feel now i'd be oh i'd
be like oh that would make things so
much easier but if i was burning 500
more calories per day i'd probably feel
the same on 2500 calories as i currently
do on 2000. yeah and so like
those are
those are counterfactuals that
you can't test within an individual and
it's it's always easy to think
man if i could if i could just eat more
this weight loss diet would be so much
easier than it currently is
but
if you were someone who could eat more
that would mean you were also burning
more and that might not actually make
the process all that much easier yeah
the the um
that pairing between your intake and
expenditure is much more impactful for
how you're feeling in that process than
just the raw absolute numbers of
calories consumed yeah for sure
um
now
one of the things i want to get at here
so we've talked about how
generally speaking energy expenditure
just measured kind of randomly at
baseline doesn't really seem to tell us
much about like how lean you're likely
to be or how your weight is likely to
change over the next several weeks
you know nonetheless i'm sure that a lot
of people are still thinking well
whatever i'll take my chances i want to
do something that
may supercharge my metabolic rate
because i have faith that once i do my
next diet i'm going to feel way better
dieting on higher calories
but built into that
is the assumption
that
everyone experiences the same change
when you go from your baseline starting
calories to negative energy balance in a
diet right so it's almost like everyone
assumes well whoever starts the diet
with 2100 calories is going to be able
to diet on higher calories than someone
who starts the diet at 1900 calories
right like it's it's all going to be
this like perfectly linear
transformation right
and unfortunately the literature casts
an extreme amount of doubt on that so
there have been two recent studies uh
one by nunes and colleagues one by
holstein and colleagues
and what they were interested in was
looking at the concept of metabolic
phenotypes right
and so
a phenotype is
broadly speaking
kind of like a set of observable
characteristics uh and in in this case
we're talking about a set of observable
characteristics that allow us to
kind of group people based on how they
react to energy right so some people are
very good at saving and conserving
energy and these people when they diet
they experience large magnitudes
magnitudes of metabolic adaptation so
they start they they get into an energy
deficit and their body is like no we're
conserving energy let's drop energy
expenditure because of that drop in
calorie intake
these folks are also good at conserving
energy on the other side of the spectrum
if they start eating more calories they
very readily store fat because that's
the most efficient thing to do energy
wise there are also people on the other
end of the spectrum who are spendthrift
metabolic phenotypes what that means is
they're very uh wasteful of energy
so when they start dieting and they get
into negative energy balance they don't
experience such large metabolic
adaptations they don't experience big
drop-offs in energy expenditure but if
you over feed them they ramp up energy
expenditure very precipitously very
rapidly and they're actually very
resistant to fat gain there have been
interesting studies where they take
people into the lab and say everyone's
eating 40 more calories than they need
for the next eight weeks right this huge
amount of overfeeding consistently well
controlled and what they find is some
people gain a ton of fat mass and some
people simply don't
some of these spendthrift individuals
just ramp up energy expenditure and they
resist that that weight gain there's
nothing mysterious about it you can look
at their energy and expenditure and say
well that's that's where the calories
went you know but there's a clear
difference
yeah they're just sitting in their their
chair basically vibrating yeah yeah so
so there's there's no mystery involved
here we can see some people are more
likely to ramp up energy expenditure
when overfed and they resist fat gain
other people much more energy efficient
if you put in energy they say cool i'll
store it for later no big deal
now the reason that this is important is
because all of the people who think it's
cool to be able to easily diet down to
the point where you have visible abs
that's cool and all
but i mean when human society falls
apart and we're all fighting over
resources
it's people like me who are going to be
on the top of the heap and that's that's
all i'm saying yeah that is very true
yeah uh be careful what you wish for i
suppose correct
um so with nunes and holstein both of
these studies were interested in looking
at metabolic phenotypes and so
holstein looked at acutely you know the
people who experience large reductions
in energy expenditure
during very short term under feeding and
overfeeding so for example if we just
have you fast for a day who has an
enormous drop in energy expenditure and
who has a much smaller drop in energy
expenditure
nunes and colleagues looked at it very
differently and looked over a longer
intervention
who seems to be resisting fat loss
versus who seems to be losing fat uh
quite readily and and very effectively
right so the people who are clearly
reducing energy expenditure and
preserving fat despite the fact that
they're trying to lose it over time
so what's really cool about these
studies
is they they look at different time
scales but they're still separating
people into these thrifty and
spendthrift
groups uh
but here's what the results indicate
in both cases the people who were
considered thrifty
uh the people who are good at conserving
energy you would say you would probably
assume well at baseline they probably
already had low energy expenditure
because these are just energy efficient
folks
not the case actually the complete
opposite of the case in both instances
the evidence would suggest that people
who experience the greatest amount of
metabolic adaptation
and by extension the people who
experience smaller increases in energy
expenditure when their calories go up
these people had higher energy
expenditure at baseline
compared to the spendthrift
individuals and so what this means is
and this is critically important and in
my opinion
the
one of the most important reasons that i
am doubtful of reverse dieting would you
maybe say that
they had high metabolic capacity at
baseline but still experienced
metabolic damage as soon as they got
into a deficit exactly yeah so even if
you said i believe reverse dieting works
as advertised literally
uh
the whole idea there is like oh well
yeah ramp up your metabolic rate and
that way that way when you start your
diet energy expenditure will be higher
and it'll be way easier next time around
what the evidence tells us is that
people who experience more considerable
metabolic adaptation their energy
expenditure is higher right before they
start that diet they already have that
higher metabolic capacity the issue is
not that they're starting at the wrong
number the issue is that when they go
into a deficit they experience a larger
drop and there's absolutely and i can't
overstate this
no evidence to suggest that reverse
dieting would change that in any way
there's no reason to believe that even
if you built up your energy expenditure
in the off season and said okay uh i
built up my energy expenditure it's time
to diet if you're the kind of person who
would actually need this intervention
more than a spendthrift individual
there is no reason to believe that
your energy expenditure is not going to
drop the same exact way the moment you
start that diet we have no reason to
believe that any buildup of metabolic
capacity before the diet will carry
forward at all
and
another important part there like i said
thrifty individuals
based on their research experience
smaller increases in energy expenditure
as their increase in calorie intake so
what that means is you know the first
part was we're granting yes as you ramp
up energy intake you're going to ramp up
energy expenditure so the first issue is
if you're someone who experiences a lot
of metabolic adaptation
it's very very doubtful that that would
carry forward at all but the second
issue is before we even get there
someone who experiences larger
magnitudes of metabolic adaptation a
thrifty individual is less likely to
even be able to ramp up through
deliberate overfeeding so deliberately
increasing calorie intake as far as we
can tell the people who actually respond
to that and would see meaningful
increases in total daily energy
expenditure are people who are
spendthrift individuals they don't even
experience really substantial metabolic
adaptation when they diet and these are
people who are are naturally quite lean
because of their innate resistance to
fat gain and so what that tells us is
based on the evidence
the people who
quote unquote need reverse dieting the
most assuming it actually did what it's
supposed to
stand to benefit the least
it's very unlikely that they're going to
be able to ramp up energy expenditure
through over feeding and even if they
did that probably doesn't matter because
once they get into a deficit they are
based on the evidence likely to
experience a substantial drop in energy
expenditure yeah
so
i know i'm running along so for some of
these parts i'm going to kind of hit the
details and again refer people to the
full article for even more nuance and
explanation
uh
one art one piece of evidence i do want
to acknowledge is a study by long
strumming colleagues which is one of the
few that actually compares
people after a bodybuilding competition
who took a kind of reverse deity
approach versus people who just said
whatever i'm going to regain weight
pretty quickly here
and the reason i highlight this paper
is essentially the analysis showed a
very straightforward pattern
and this was a case a case series so
this is not like
a randomized controlled trial
uh this is not um the type of thing
where
you know you're gonna be able to make
super super
uh strong claims based on you know
the reverse diet versus alternative
strategies were not strictly controlled
by the research team and things like
that um but but basically this was a
study that i collaborated on with some
really excellent researchers looking at
uh physique athletes after a competition
who are just doing what they what they
think is best for themselves right a
very hands-off approach but the
statistical analysis showed some pretty
straightforward patterns where the the
folks who just let themselves regain
some weight and some fat mass after the
show um you know
they recovered quite well from all that
stuff that we would kind of lump under
that metabolic adaptation umbrella so uh
the hormone changes the the metabolic
rate changes those were expedited by
just saying you know what i'm gonna go
ahead and let myself regain some weight
uh the people who appeared to
try to keep body weight pretty stable
and just slowly ramp up calorie intake
based on the measurements taken it seems
like that really interfered with the
recovery of hormone levels and the
recovery of metabolic rate
and so without painting with too broad
of a brush
simply put in this study which is the
most direct evidence we have of
something that would be called reverse
dieting it just really fell flat it
seemed to really
delay recovery from an intense diet and
essentially
failed to deliver on a lot of those
promises uh by which it's marketed this
idea that oh no it'll facilitate
recovery but you don't have to deal with
all that unwanted fat gain uh you know
these results directly oppose that
concept and suggest that the
reluctance to regain some weight in that
process uh it does in fact kind of stop
some of that recovery in its tracks yeah
um
now
just just take your time cover
everything you want to my segment ran
long as well
just
you know what let's let's try to make
this
as as good and thorough of a piece of
audio content as possible let's sure
let's not rush it yeah let's take our
time then so at this point just kind of
recapping metabolic adaptation exists
it's impermanent
uh it does add some friction to the
weight loss process but it does not make
way for the weight loss impossible nor
does it guarantee you're going to regain
weight so that's really important
second of all we can categorize people
into these metabolic phenotypes based on
who experiences more metabolic
adaptation and who experiences less
what we know from that research
is that the folks who experience a lot
of metabolic adaptation which again does
add some friction in weight loss
those folks actually tend to have higher
energy expenditure at baseline before
the weight loss diet begins so the idea
that they are struggling because they
didn't build up their metabolic capacity
is directly contradicted by the research
available
the research available would also
suggest
that those folks even if they wanted to
increase calories to build up their
metabolic rate are actually least likely
to be able to do that
because they you know people who have
this thrifty phenotype do not experience
these robust increases in energy
expenditure when their energy intake
starts to drift upward so what that
means is
it doesn't look like building up
metabolic capacity is the problem in the
first place
it doesn't look like even if you did it
it would carry forward into the next
dieting phase it should basically just
vanish immediately when you start
dieting again and it's very unlikely
that the people who need it the most the
people who experience the greatest
metabolic adaptation would even be able
to do it
because of that lack of increase in
energy expenditure during over feeding
the idea
that you can do this reverse dieting to
get all the benefits of recovering from
a previous weight loss diet without
weight gain uh or without considerable
weight gain is actually directly
contradicted by evidence and
directly contradicted by the most
relevant evidence that we have available
of course a randomized controlled trial
would be better but we have to go with
the evidence that we have currently
the next thing i want to address is
kind of an extension of
what i mentioned previously so we've
talked a little bit about metabolic
phenotypes and say well okay the people
who
would be most interested in building up
metabolic capacity through reverse
dieting first of all seem to have the
least capacity to do it but also have
uh larger drops in energy expenditure
when they shift to a diet anyway
but another thing that is important to
ask yourself before that
before you even get into phenotypes is
well
who is actually interested in this
concept in the first place like who are
the people who are saying i need to
reverse diet because
my i'm having troubles with weight loss
and the way that i'm pursuing weight
loss is unsustainable it's usually
people who are
relatively predisposed to fat gain in
the first place you know it's very rare
that i hear someone who says yeah i'm
naturally very lean i have been all my
life uh but metabolic adaptation is
really holding me back here yeah someone
who can get in stage ready condition on
like 2 400 calories per day they're not
trying to reverse diet like they're
they're in pretty good shape yeah and so
that brings me to another point which is
related to metabolic phenotypes in a way
but you know what we find during
controlled overfeeding studies is like i
said previously
some people do
experience large increases in energy
expenditure and they very strongly
resist fat gain
and i'll show an image on the screen
that demonstrates some of this data from
levine and colleagues
uh on the other hand a lot of
individuals experience minimal change in
energy expenditure and they very readily
and rapidly
gain fat and so what that tells us is
people who are
likely to report a history of struggling
with weight loss
people who are likely to be pursuing
weight loss goals in the first place um
almost by definition are folks who
probably don't have this
in this context this advantage of being
resistant to fat gain in the first place
it kind of gives us an indicator that
the people who are most interested in
exploiting this concept of reverse
dieting or utilizing it in their own
fitness journey
they are probably
not these
individuals who are in the spendthrift
phenotype who are resistant to fat gain
in the first place so it puts us in a
position where based on all the evidence
we've covered so far the people who are
most interested interested in using this
again
this type of strategy even if it worked
would be least accessible to those
individuals
those individuals
now
moving on
there's one additional thing i want to
mention here
in terms of overfeeding
and that is the fact that a lot of these
overfeeding studies are are commonly
used to support claims about reverse
dieting they say well look at the group
level you you put these people in this
huge caloric surplus and their energy
expenditure goes up therefore we're
going to build up your metabolic rate in
the off season right as i've already
covered that interpretation fully
ignores the concept of metabolic
phenotypes which is a major oversight
but an even bigger oversight is the fact
that it treats
just overfeeding from a natural body
weight as if it's the same thing
as increasing calories after weight loss
yeah so when we look at weight reduced
individuals whether they lost their
weight five years ago or five days ago
being in a weight reduced state is a
unique physiological state so i
mentioned previously all of these
different factors that that occur with
with weight regain we talk about how
there's an immediate response when you
go from negative to neutral energy
balance right but it's not very
impactful
until people get back to a somewhat
similar body fat level in the weight
regain process
there's ample
tremendous amounts of evidence to show
that people preferentially regain fat
and they do that very very efficiently
so the fact that you have previously
lost weight
especially if it happened recently
very dramatically
influences your response to overfeeding
even if you were someone who might have
experienced this adaptive increase in
energy expenditure
doing that after a weight loss phase is
exceedingly unlikely what we see in
virtually all of the weight regained
literature is that if you have
previously lost weight and you start
ramping calories up you will very
efficiently regain fat mass uh that has
been shown
many many many different times uh and so
i'll put that i put that image up
previously with the dulu study where
they uh they highlight an entire body of
literature indicating that
weight regain is a kind of unique being
in a weight reduced state is a unique
physiological state yeah over feeding
after a diet is extremely different
physiologically than overfeeding from
your natural body weight and so this
idea that we can just kind of slowly
ramp up calories and for some reason
contrary to all the pre-existing
evidence your body is going to decide to
burn those calories rather than storing
uh it just it just contradicts volumes
of research on weight regain
yeah it reminds me of uh
i don't know how popular this still is
but maybe like three to five years ago
um it was a
popular idea put forth in in the
bodybuilding community that
after a bodybuilding competition you
were as lean as you were ever going to
get so your your insulin sensitivity was
as high as it was ever going to get
there was going to be a huge nutrient
partitioning advantage uh so if you
started over feeding from that point
you'd be able to gain a ton of muscle
and partially in support of that people
would cite a study by forbes based on
overfeeding research showing that
in general leaner people without a
resistance training stimulus you just
give them more calories they gain weight
but a larger proportion of the weight
they gain was lean mass versus people
with more body fat you over feed them a
larger proportion of the weight they
gain would be fat mass
and they just assumed that that would
generalize but the forbes data was based
on people who were in neutral energy
balance not in a weight reduced state
and then overfed versus you know
bodybuilders physique athletes after a
show
very much in a weight reduced state and
so people were putting forth this idea
but all of the controlled research all
of the case studies on bodybuilders and
physique athletes showed the exact
opposite like basically what you're
saying when they did
overfeed to a large extent after a show
you know you would see a bump in lean
mass just from you know
body water glycogen resynthesis etc but
mostly preferential fat gain and i think
that idea has lost some popularity in
recent years
i i think just because it didn't play
out in the real world like in in theory
people thought it made sense not
accounting for the fact that you know
weight neutral and weight reduced
individuals very different sets of of
like physiological baselines there um
and yeah like i i think
i basically think a lot of bodybuilders
uh especially like natural bodybuilders
tried to do that like oh i'm gonna get
shredded and then i'm gonna put on like
10 pounds of muscle as i rebound from
the show
and like it just didn't work out for any
of them yeah and uh
so yeah like i i i think
the bodybuilding community has started
to learn its lesson from that but yeah
the the basic principle extends to other
populations as well
yeah i mean and we see in in weight loss
trials after weight loss is achieved
weight regain is very common but it
happens gradually over time uh it seems
hard to imagine that whether we're
looking at a randomized controlled trial
in an obese population or we're looking
at uh a study in extremely lean physique
athletes i'm trying to find the instance
where if you just go slow enough like
over feeding just supercharges your
metabolic rate and you for some reason
don't regain fat the weight reduced
state makes us uh
very efficient at regaining fat and
there's really no evidence to suggest
that simply going slower is going to
somehow rectify or circumvent that and
actually that's a really nice transition
to a
a good example of that so
you mentioned previously proof of
concept studies um so you you're talking
previously about
calf stretching and muscle growth and
how sometimes we look at a study that's
the most extreme case
just to say okay
if this is ever gonna work
it's gonna work in this really extreme
instance yeah and then we can refine it
from there and see if it matters in
practical day-to-day strategies right so
with that in mind i'm going to lean on
the minnesota starvation experiment
and this was a very extreme experiment
where uh
the participants in the study
got very very very lean so they
demonstrated some of the largest
magnitudes of metabolic adaptation that
have ever been documented in
well-controlled research so if a
strategy about attenuating or reversing
metabolic adaptation was ever going to
work
this was the study where it ought to
work
and so a lot of people say that they're
going to use reverse dieting because
for some reason after weight loss if you
simply go slow enough with your
increases in calories uh it will set you
up for a smoother transition to your
maintenance phase or attenuate weight
regain as you're doing that transition
so people often talk about this
experiment by keys and colleagues
and they often talk about the metabolic
adaptation component because it's flashy
and it's the biggest numbers ever
observed
to my knowledge and it was kind of the
the first time that people said whoa
look at these crazy adaptations to
weight loss but there was a refeeding
component and there was a stratified
refeeding component so they put people
uh into these four different groups t g
l and z
and they basically said okay group z
we're going to give you a much smaller
kind of transition into this refeeding
so smaller and slower calorie increases
uh
group l we're going to ramp you up
faster so bigger calorie increases more
more rapidly out of the gate group g was
a little faster group t even faster
and what they looked at was there was
this controlled 12-week overfeeding
period
and then a
non-controlled overfeeding period after
that where they said okay now do your
thing and eat what you want you know
which is how we all live our lives right
so you know
no one is like sitting there like yeah i
just finished my diet and i'm waiting
for
some authority figure to deliver my
meals for the day because you know all
of my intake is perfectly controlled at
the end of the day real world scenarios
we're all left to our own devices there
right but anyway in this controlled over
feeding period if you look at the rate
of weight gain in that slow group
uh
they honestly didn't gain an apprecia
appreciable amount of weight over the
first six weeks of refeeding
which is remarkable because again we're
talking about people
who were safely
on the brink of starvation i mean they
were close right it was monitored it was
medically supervised but these people
were shredded and they were not eating
much yeah and they were doing a lot of
activity as well
this this was before the declaration of
helsinki right indeed when you could
still
uh get away with some [ __ ] and research
that probably you shouldn't exactly yeah
so i mean they basically stayed weight
stable for the first six weeks of
controlled overfeeding it was a very
gradual thing that
i think you could argue is relatively
reminiscent of what people suggest
reverse dieting ought to look like uh
and so at the end of this 12-week period
they started out the first six weeks
basically weight stable and then it
starts to creep up and they've gained an
appreciable amount of weight by week 12
but there's very clear gaps the slower
uh refeeding groups regained less weight
over 12 weeks than the faster reefy in
groups because of course they did they
that's how numbers work with calorie
surpluses right yeah the question is
well what happens after they go to the
ad libitum stage where they're able to
eat whatever they want and it you know
they're left to their own devices much
like we are in the real world the slower
groups just regain like they completely
closed the gap yeah they very promptly
went right back to the same approximate
body weight as the folks who just gained
it earlier and so in this instance in
the most extreme
application of metabolic adaptation
those short-term benefits of kind of
slowing the process over the first 12
weeks
they yielded virtually no benefit that
persisted beyond the next like couple
months
once they were back to ad libitum
feeding
they very promptly basically caught up
with the fat gain of the other groups so
the other groups kind of trended they
kind of tapered off um as we would
anticipate based on what we've talked
about with fat mass dictating a lot of
that process and the groups that took it
slower they just caught up and they
caught up very quickly yeah so what
we're seeing here is that
as i've stated previously the people who
are most interested in reverse dieting
uh even if it worked it would be less
accessible to them
but based on the literature we really
have
no reason to believe that it should work
or more importantly that it does work uh
it's it's not like there's evidence of
this working and we just haven't figured
out why yeah we know why it shouldn't
and we have also seen
that if it did
it's just not happening in any of the
most well-controlled studies that are
most relevant yeah so it shouldn't work
based on what we know and based on what
we've observed
it doesn't appear to work yeah and i i
certainly acknowledge that we haven't
done a lot of direct study on controlled
reverse dieting interventions
but at this point it's almost hard to
justify doing it yeah uh there's just
not enough of a of a kernel of
optimism in the literature where you
would say this is a worthwhile thing
that
we ought to do a huge randomized
controlled trial on
that makes sense to me but here's
ooh i'll do a little segue for you wow
so with all of that being said
it still seems like there are a lot of
people who have tried reverse dieting
and they they think it worked for them
so what might be going on in those
situations yeah so i believe that there
are four what i call illusions that make
reverse dieting in the real world in
practice seem more useful than it is and
before i get into it i do want to
acknowledge that uh what i'm doing here
is not doubting the experience of people
who have noted uh you know positive
experiences here um you know it's really
important to clarify i'm not saying that
uh you're lying or you're
misinterpreting what what what occurred
um
well i guess i am saying you're
misinterpreting but uh basically
i'm not indicating that someone you're
not grossly and maliciously
misinterpreting right yeah i'm not
saying oh you're full of crap i'm not
saying oh you're foolish for being
misled by these illusions i'm arguing
that there are things that occur during
overfeeding
that
very
are they're very compelling illusions if
you were doing it you would have every
reason to believe what i'm doing right
now is absolutely working as intended
yeah right you're you're reaching
incorrect but
uh
very very understandable incorrect
conclusions absolutely these are
conclusions that i would not fault
anyone for reaching or sharing with
excitement right so
uh illusion number one pertains to
simply just improved consistency
of dietary tracking and improved
adherence to one's dietary targets so
if we look at the literature we'll see
that
registered dietitians who are i would
say the most well-trained nutrition
profession in the united states but
that's not really an arguable statement
they have the most hands-on direct
training for
what it's like you know in day-to-day
dietary uh interventions or treatment
programs right so very well-trained
nutrition professionals
they have about a 20 error in the
research when when you say okay how much
are you eating and then you actually go
verify how much they're eating like they
have a 20
underestimation of their actual energy
intake
and again that's highly trained folks
eating the stuff they normally eat
just trying to do their normal thing not
trying to do any changes with dynamic
targets fluctuating not trying to eat
foods they're not used to that's just
like a baseline 20 underestimation
when we look at research and people who
report a history of
being unable to lose weight despite very
low calorie intakes we find that they
they often
underestimate their calorie intake by
about 50 percent
while simultaneously overestimating
their physical activity again by about
50 percent
so we know that it's very very common
and understandable for people to
underestimate their intake when they are
not watching it like a hawk right and so
you introduce an intervention like
reverse dieting
and
in many cases you have people saying
well the intervention here the
magic is that this week we're adding 5
grams of carbs to your diet or 10 grams
of carbs to your diet
necessarily it insists upon a level of
consistency and precision with tracking
that
in my opinion over the long term is
unsustainable but if nothing else makes
you say if i don't track every little
trace of my diet
i might lose the entire intervention
yeah right like if being off by 10 grams
turns it from an intervention to not an
intervention you must be perfect yeah
and so if we look at the magnitude of
common underestimation even in people
who are doing a pretty damn good job
with their tracking
it's not unreasonable to suggest that
some people will
find
an extra few hundred calories when they
start tracking with this level of
precision
and what that means is someone will
think back to their
a previous time where they are at a
similar body weight and they say you
know back then when i was like kind of
loosely doing a pretty okay job tracking
back then i was maintaining this body at
2200 calories a day but now i'm
maintaining a very similar body at 2600
calories per day so my energy
expenditure i've ramped it up 400
calories
it's very possible that in many cases
you've simply identified the extra 400
calories that historically were not
being consistently tracked either
because your day-to-day tracking had
some error or back then you didn't think
twice about finishing the kids leftovers
just to avoid food waste or back then
you didn't really worry about the extra
two beers on saturday watching the
football game
so we can find extra calories through
extremely precise tracking that actually
look very similar to the purported
increase in energy expenditure with
reverse dieting in some of these
anecdotes yeah
uh
illusion number two is that practically
speaking a person's a person's
maintenance calorie target is more like
a range of targets right
so for example if your true
total daily energy expenditure
is 2200 calories a day
uh and in this scenario we're going to
pretend it never changes it's totally
stable so eating 2 200 calories every
single day should keep your body weight
totally flat in this hypothetical yeah
if you were to drop it to 2100 you would
be in a 100 calorie deficit
it would probably take you
a pretty long time to figure out that
you're actually losing weight right so
you're in 100 calories you're eating a
hundred calories below your actual
maintenance level but like if you just
crunch the numbers it should take you
over three months to lose a kilogram and
then you factor in the fact that every
day our body weight is constantly
bouncing up and down because of water
and sodium and glycogen and all that
crap
and
the bulk content in our gi tract so
basically what i'm implying here is that
for a lot of people
it might be hard without like some kind
of nice weight trending software and
without very diligent tracking it might
be really hard if you have a total daily
energy expenditure of 2 200 calories a
day to actually
know with any degree of certainty that
if you're eating 2 000 calories per day
you're actually in a deficit or if
you're eating 2 400 calories per day
you're actually in a surplus it could
take you literally months to figure that
out and then to become a parent and
that's assuming that
your
your maintenance
energy expenditure
is perfectly static correct because i
mean there there is like an actual range
on top of that yes like you know your
your maintenance range might be
21 to 2300 calories so if you go down to
21 you are still at maintenance like
your your need goes down a little bit
you're
at
that level it probably wouldn't actually
be reductions in resting energy
expenditure but you know you like neat
can adapt 200 calories like pretty
easily yeah um so yeah like in in in
that case you know maybe you were
maintaining at
2000 or like 2100 before and now you get
up to 2 300. it's like oh i built my
metabolic capacity no like both both of
those were already
calorie intakes in the first place you
just kind of found the top of that range
yeah which which might be nice but it's
it's not a unique adaptation correct and
so for a lot of people i i do wonder to
what extent some of these positive
anecdotes of of reverse dieting are
people who
didn't really recognize that they were
either at the bottom of that range or
even in a small deficit
and you know they're just like oh yeah i
guess i'm maintaining weight
approximately at 2 000 calories and then
they don't really realize that they're
in a slight caloric surplus when they're
at 2400 calories and they say whoa
i just increased my energy expenditure
400 calories a day
and we can explain that uh pretty
concisely without any physiological
adaptations needed yeah uh the third
illusion that i refer to in my article
is that
calorie intake we view it
instantaneously right so when when we
bump our calories to 3 000 a day we say
i eat 3 000 calories per day and we
don't really think about well what was
my kind of trajectory of calorie intake
over the last six months or over the
last 12 months right
so we we talk about calorie intake in an
instant instantaneous way but body
weight change and body composition
change is cumulative in nature
right so for example
let's say hypothetically you finish a
diet you accomplish your weight loss
goal at the end of the diet your energy
expenditure every day is 2600 calories a
day
and you decide okay i'm just going to do
a maintenance phase and keep my intake
at 2 600 calories
16 weeks later
still taking in 2600 calories you still
weigh the same again it's an
oversimplification that
implies that everything's static and
never changes but but that's where we're
at
now let's say
that
you finish your diet
and your energy expenditure's still 2
600 calories per day but
you ended the diet consuming 2
225 calories a day
right so you're in you're in a deficit
that makes sense because you're losing
weight right so instead of just jumping
to 2600 you say i'm actually gonna
slowly build this up over time right and
so very linearly in a stepwise manner
every week you make a change and you
build up from 20
225 up to 2975
calories per day so you just keep
ramping it up
at the end of that 16 week period making
a change at the beginning of each week
building up to 29.75
you're thinking whoa when i compare this
to the alternative i've built up my
metabolic rate by almost 400 calories
i'm maintaining the same weight but
instead of eating 2600 calories per day
i'm eating 2975.
the reality is that both of those
strategies have the same cumulative
energy balance because during the first
part of that reverse diet
you were still in a fairly substantial
calorie deficit you didn't actually get
into neutral energy balance until about
halfway through it and then you know the
other half you know when you're looking
at that intake of 29.75 you are in a
small surplus but you just got there and
so you have not had time to accumulate
that body fat so it's an illusion by
which instead of just jumping to
maintenance if we ramp it up over 16
weeks it looks like we built up
metabolic capacity by 400 calories per
day but we can fully explain that with
math that requires no increase in energy
expenditure whatsoever those are two
mathematically equivalent approaches in
terms of the cumulative amount of energy
that would be stored yeah yeah uh now
we can look at another example where
let's say instead of trying to maintain
you say whatever i'm cool with a little
bit of weight gain right so you finish
your diet uh total energy expenditure is
2600 calories per day and so you decide
i'm just going to bump up to 29.75 right
out of the gate so the last example
that's what you built up to in this case
you say whatever i'm fine with a little
a little bit of weight regain i'm gonna
bump up 29.75 every day 16 weeks
eventually you have a positive energy
balance over time
of 42 000 calories of extra calories
coming in
now in a different scenario you can
start at the same place and say
i'm going to start at 2 225
just like i did in the last reverse
dieting example
but
i'm going to ramp up very aggressively
the change i make every week is going to
be twice as big at the end of this six
16 week period i'm going to ramp all the
way up to 30 to
725 calories we're talking about over 3
700 calories a day that's a massive
calorie intake for a lot of people
so if you take that approach instead and
you work up from 2225
up to
3725 you still have a cumulative energy
balance of 42 000 calories per day so
these two approaches
jumping straight to 29.75 or working up
to 37.25
the cumulative impact on on energy
balance is the same
so one person would look back and say
yeah i gained some weight but
i'm only eating
2975 calories a day the other person
would say well i've gained the same
amount of weight but i'm eating 3 700.
like i've clearly built up my metabolic
capacity by 800 calories
that's not the case
when we look at these short time scales
and these fixed time scales we find that
ramping your way up can create this
illusion
that your energy expenditure has
dramatically changed
in the short term it's difficult to see
that but if people continue this you
know so in this example
you know the one person keeps eating
29.75 the other person continues
building or stays at 3 700 calories a
day
over time those body composition
differences are going to become very
substantial and very apparent and the
reason that's important is because i
often see anecdotes of people saying
you know i've been doing this reverse
dieting and
i'm just amazed at how lean i am at my
current calorie intake
and it's almost always people who have
been ramping up their calories over the
last month or two
it's very rarely someone who says
yeah this is crazy i i've been doing
very meticulous tracking my entire
fitness journey and now
for very long time scales i just eat a
thousand calories more than i used to
it's way more rare to see that and it's
exceedingly more rare to see people say
yeah i did this in the off season and
now that i'm dieting it's a breeze
because again
a lot of times that initial inflation of
energy intake is actually more of an
illusion than anything
and any metabolic changes that actually
do occur during that time period
probably go away the moment you start
dieting yeah or
i mean to to the extent where it's not
an illusion like and this is something
we've talked about off mike before but
like i i think um
i do
think reverse dieting can work
not necessarily for the reasons that are
advertised but as
kind of a trick to convince people to
actually be in a caloric surplus for
once yeah uh like like people who
are trying to be super lean all the time
they're chronic dieters
and they they've never really given
themselves
a longish term energy surplus to
actually like build some muscle and be
able to train hard and not be super
fatigued like
if you can convince them oh yeah ramp up
your calories gradually you're not going
to gain much fat which if you told them
on the front end like oh yeah you
totally are they wouldn't listen to you
in the first place right so you
you can kind of trick them into actually
getting into a surplus for a while
building muscle and then yeah maybe
their next diet does go better and maybe
their energy expenditure
is a little bit higher at the end of the
diet but it's not necessarily because
they quote unquote built up their
metabolic capacity due to the reverse
diet itself
you just you just finally tricked them
to get into a surplus for the first time
in five years right and uh you know the
the bot the
ability to to build muscle and train
hard from getting in that surplus uh
was the thing that helped them in their
subsequent weight loss phase yeah and
another thing you know like we mentioned
previously it kind of tricks people into
saying well we're going to do even if
it's not a surplus if you say well we're
going to do a maintenance phase
but you're actually going to really
meticulously track a lot of people very
understandably so during a maintenance
phase they say oh cool like this is the
time i'll just make sure body weight is
pretty stable uh you know when it starts
drifting up i'll tighten things up if it
starts drifting down i'll tighten things
up and kind of course correct and keep
body weight stable
but in that in that context the
maintenance phase works fine
but people often often underestimate
their actual calorie intake during the
maintenance phase for a lot of people
it's the first time that they've
committed to a long maintenance phase
and actually gotten a very good
accurate quantification of how many
calories they eat during a maintenance
phase yeah so yeah that's definitely
part of it
uh and then the final thing i want to
mention here
is an illusion that involves an
inversion of cause and effect
because
you know i mentioned previously that
when someone after a weight loss diet
goes
from an energy deficit to energy balance
there are real things that happen like
maintenance phases have physiological
impacts you know we we do see a small
partial restoration of total daily
energy expenditure for a lot of folks we
do see a partial or full attenuation of
some of those symptoms of relative
energy deficiency and in some people
this can create
subjective improvements in quality of
life and just how they feel that have
really important impacts on their
activity level the way that they train
like
going from a deficit to a maintenance is
a real intervention that does real
physiological changes
and most importantly those have been
documented
we look at the research and say what
happens when a person who's been dieting
goes to maintenance we can look at
actual evidence and say how it affects
how they feel their energy expenditure
the way they train their activity level
those are real things that the
physiology literature fully accounts for
one thing that we cannot
look at the literature for is saying
well but then what happens if i increase
my carbs by 10 grams every day yeah uh
there's no evidence to suggest that's a
physiological relevant intervention that
would do anything other than eventually
if you do it long enough and do some
extra weight gain right and so when i
talk about cause and effect the reason
this comes up is because
a lot of times people frame reverse
dieting as well i was at neutral energy
balance right
at my low crappy post-diet energy
expenditure but when i bumped my carbs
up 10 grams my body decided for some
reason contrary to everything we know
about weight regain and post diet fat
storage i'm instead going to ramp up my
energy expenditure to match that why
i literally have no idea yeah but i'm
gonna do that and then that happens and
then you increase your carbs 10 grams
again and your body says again i have no
regard for the weight regained
literature i'm going to do a thing
that's never actually really been
observed and bump up again and match
that and for some reason this weight
reduced body has decided
this is my my permanent body weight and
if you keep ramping up calories i
promise to keep increasing energy
expenditure to match it
that's never been observed and nothing
close to it has been observed
uh
but what has been observed is that when
you go from a deficit to maintenance
energy expenditure does increase a
little bit
and so what i posit in this article
is that
reverse dieting is the effect
of establishing neutral energy balance
it is not the cause that is ramping up
energy expenditure so rather than saying
because i increased my carbs 10 grams my
body is elevating my energy expenditure
i think it works the other way around
i think it's i was dieting right and so
my energy expenditure was suppressed
when i went from negative to neutral
energy balance
all of a sudden all of a sudden i'm in
what we would call a maintenance phase
you know and i'm in neutral energy
balance and in response to that my
energy expenditure probably will go up a
little bit
not all the way to where it started but
a little bit and we have ample evidence
to suggest that that happens we're in
the research again we're not in the
imaginary world right
and so as a result oh wow i jumped to
maintenance and then my energy
expenditure bumped up a little bit and
actually over time because of that
it looks like my weight is actually
starting to drop just a tiny bit
you know and so
because i have restored neutral energy
balance eventually i actually have the
opportunity in the future to increase my
carbs by 10 grams just to get back to
neutral energy balance right so i
started in this huge deficit i closed
that gap and then my energy expenditure
creeps up a little bit which has been
observed and so now i have to bump my my
calories up a little bit just to stay in
neutral energy balance and so what i
believe is happening based on the
evidence is that reverse dieting is this
gradual increase in calories
is enabled by getting back to
approximately neutral energy balance
instead of staying in the deficit and so
what we see is yes
over time a person can
gradually increase their calories a
little bit by little bit by little bit
and stay relatively weight neutral over
that time period but it's not because
the the 10 grams of carbs are doing
something special that's never been
observed in the literature it's because
getting to approximately maintenance is
doing something that absolutely has been
observed in literature and so we're able
to continue bumping calories up because
we are keeping pace with an energy
expenditure that is very subtly climbing
because instead of being in this big
prolonged deficit we're doing our best
to stay in approximately neutral energy
balance
and the analogy i draw on there is
related to uh
brian miner and eric helms and i don't
know if they had other authors on that
paper
um they published a really insightful
article about uh
basically how we view progressive
overload with resistance training right
and so
um we don't need a maximal training
stimulus every workout to be able to
make adaptation we just we just need the
training stimulus to be good enough to
impose more adaptation and so they
basically say you know you're not doing
progressive overload you're not causing
it by adding five pounds on the bar
what's happening is you're giving an
adequate training stimulus you're
getting stronger and you're adding five
pounds on the bar to make sure that the
the training stimulus
continues to be adequate so you're
adding pounds on the bar because you're
getting stronger versus every little
minute change in training load making
this enormous difference in terms of
your progression over time yeah so i
think it's a genealogy just to state
that another way yeah adding five more
pounds to the bar doesn't force you to
get stronger yes you're able to add five
more pounds to the bar because you have
already gotten stronger exactly
and in an analogous way
10 grams of carbs is not forcing your
energy expenditure upward to a
meaningful degree
you are able to add in an additional 10
grams because you have been
instead of being in a debt in a deficit
you have gotten close to to you know
approximately neutral energy balance and
your energy expenditure is responding in
kind
so uh those are the four illusions that
i think are contributing to why we see
so many of these positive anecdotes and
again they are
compelling they are convincing and i do
not fault anyone for
for saying wow this this really looks
like it's doing something as i mentioned
simply being in maintenance
does real physiological things compared
to being in a deficit so i'm not even
saying that nothing's happening during
reverse dieting but what i am saying is
that reverse dieting in most
applications
uh
is really just a more stressful
mechanism of getting into
a maintenance phase or getting into
neutral energy balance which does
actually do things right so people might
experience
positive things during a reverse diet
but the only positive uh physiological
things going on that have
that would make sense in a reverse diet
would also be absolutely accomplished by
simply doing a maintenance phase
and
working up to it slowly doesn't really
seem to add any benefit uh if you have a
good estimate of what your energy
expenditure is at the end of a diet you
should be able to jump straight to it uh
and enjoy all of those benefits of
neutral energy balance without delaying
that process yeah and kind of saying
well i'm going to stay in a deficit and
just bump up 10 grams at a time until i
get there right yeah
so
one of the things that people often ask
um
on this topic
is like is there ever a reason to try
reverse dieting you know and we own
macro factor and for
all the reasons i just talked about for
way too long we don't have a reverse
diet function because frankly i
i don't think the evidence is there i
don't want to take users on this ride
where they spin their wheels and have
these really high expectations and
ultimately end up disappointed you know
it's
it's an evidence-based app and we want
to make sure that we are
providing all the best features that we
can possibly provide that are also
compatible with the evidence yeah right
um but people still ask like hey um
you know is there ever a reason to try
reverse dieting uh
one good reason is you're just curious
and you want to try it yeah there's
nothing wrong with that i
i don't lose sleep over the idea that
someone out there is currently reverse
dieting right so if you're really
intrigued to really interested
absolutely you're welcome to it and we
design macro factor in a way that
enables that you know and we've got a
thing on the knowledge but the knowledge
base that tells you how to do that but
basically just setting an extremely slow
weight gain goal
it just provides that little upward
pressure on your calorie target
boom you've done a reverse diet but it's
not some special feature that we're
willing to advertise and say hey come
check out this incredible new thing that
defies physiology right if you want to
try to just set the lowest possible rate
of weight gain
and see if it nudges your calories
upward
you know by all means if you're just
interested that's fine
you can do it in macro factor or you can
do it without macro factor doesn't
really matter
but i think the most justifiable
scenario for why you might
want to try reverse dieting
is you just finished a fat loss phase
and you'd like to maintain
you know basically all of your weight
loss in the long term you're very
adamant that you don't want to regain
weight uh your energy intake your
calorie target at the end of your diet
is a bit unsustainable for you so you're
like okay i want to maintain this
physique exactly
i don't want to regain fat but i don't
think i can maintain this low calorie
intake for a long time
uh
but
you also don't really know what your
total daily energy expenditure is you
know what you've been eating and you
know that it's been promoting weight
loss but you're not really sure what
your energy expenditure is
in that scenario
there is a possibility that just
guessing your energy expenditure and
therefore your target for calories in a
maintenance phase
you could overestimate that energy
expenditure and therefore the calorie
target
and if it's a substantial overestimation
you might regain fat because like we've
said all the evidence suggests that if
you recently lost weight you are
physiologically primed for some pretty
efficient fat regain right so in that
scenario
i do think it makes sense
theoretically to say
well instead of making a guess that i
don't feel good about maybe i'll just
slowly work up and test the waters i'll
keep those illusions previously
mentioned in mind and i'll try to settle
on a maintenance phase that's going to
work for the long term
now
your energy expenditure might go up in
the process as you get more from a
deficit to neutral energy balance is
that going to make your next diet easier
probably not you'll probably still
experience metabolic adaptation next
time around once you get back into a
sizeable energy deficit but it basically
the concept of reverse dieting functions
as a way to work toward a maintenance
target when you're not certain of what
it is likely to be and you're very
adamant that you don't want to regain
any fat
but i will also mention that one of the
reasons we don't offer that feature in
macro factor
aside from the lack of evidence and the
excessive hype that comes with that term
is the fact that if you're using macro
factor
the guesswork is gone you know we keep a
very well calculated running estimate of
your total daily energy expenditure so
the moment you stop a diet a weight loss
diet and switch to maintenance we're not
just guessing you know we haven't we
have empirical data to indicate what
your most likely maintenance target is
we put you there and then we have a
dynamic
maintenance
approach where
if your energy expenditure does start
creeping up because you've gone from a
deficit to neutral energy balance
the app will pick up on that in your
weight trend and it will increase your
calorie target so basically again the
reverse dieting might occur
you know in the sense that calories
might creep up over time but that's the
effect of the maintenance phase not
something that is causing this
previously unidentified physiological
effect yeah right yeah
so um
i think that pretty much does it i just
want to wrap up with some practical
applications uh there's really no
evidence to suggest that reverse dieting
accomplishes
anything more than a fairly standard
maintenance phase
when it comes to metabolic adaptation
this is not something that stops weight
loss in its tracks it's not something
that guarantees weight regain and so
what we should be trying to do is simply
quantify it and account for it so as
you're dieting it's nice to see how your
expenditure is changing so that you can
simply keep either making calorie
adjustments to accommodate it or extend
your weight loss timeline to accommodate
it because both of those options should
be effective based on the actual
research in human beings losing weight
and that is really what we use to guide
our the way we approach things in macro
factor or to
or to use it as an indication to maybe
try to increase activity levels yes yeah
that is absolutely another way that you
could uh account for metabolic
adaptation but
we're not trying to
totally stifle it or circumvent it or
fix it or anything like that because you
know as we talked about the
the available evidence does not really
leave wiggle room for the concept that
reverse dieting is going to you know
really effectively and robustly and
persistently reverse these things
[Music]
so if you're interested in reverse
dieting just because you're curious or
because you want to transition to a
long-term maintenance phase and you
don't know what your target should be i
do think it's justifiable but for most
cases
i think just a a pretty simple
maintenance phase
should be
should be good enough to get the job
done there and based on the evidence a
maintenance phase
can be a really positive thing but
there's really no evidence of
and
really no evidence supporting the
theoretical concepts that reverse
dieting should really be any more
effective than a maintenance phase
well
based on where this segment started uh
when you asked me
what good things i thought reverse
dieting would do for me personally uh i
have to say that i'm very upset with how
this segment went you've dashed all of
my hopes upon the rocks
uh but i will try to be strong and
uh
adapt to this very unfortunate
information that you're giving me well i
i appreciate your resiliency uh in the
face of this bad news
um
one closing comment that i want to
reiterate
in this segment i talked about how
we approach these types of things in
macro factor
and the reason is we developed the app
to
accommodate challenges in
you know the process of trying to gain
weight lose weight maintain weight etc
so it's really important to recognize
you can take all this information and
use it and never spend a cent on macro
factor and that's fine you don't need
macro factor to apply any of this
information
um
and yeah like i like like we said
previously uh the purpose here was not
to sell you on macro factor it was just
to kind of
readjust the public perception of
reverse dieting because it seems to have
just taken on a life of its own and
gotten so far from the evidence that we
really do need to rein it back in a
little bit
um
yeah so uh
there's uh
you don't need macro factor to make any
of this information useful and as we
mentioned previously my only conflicts
of interest would lead me to say
actually
reverse dieting very effective
in fact find the first study that ever
mentioned it it's mine i'm a visionary
and also let's throw it in the app and
market it and make a bunch of money off
of it uh but we haven't done that and
uh to be very
to be very honest
it would have been way quicker and
easier to just put it in the app than to
write the 60 page article explaining why
it's not in the app you know
it's just we don't believe in it you
know and so that that's why we don't
have it yeah but i will say if the
evidence comes around and i have to eat
my words and say actually 2014 eric was
way smarter than 2022 eric
we can always put it in well i mean
if anything it's more grotesque than
that because initially you put forth the
idea of reverse dieting and to be clear
i didn't make it up i was the first
person to mention it in a peer-reviewed
paper yeah but you know you did that and
now in this article you are you're
publicly eating crow
but to extend the metaphor you're going
to have to figure out how to regurgitate
the crow
and bring it back to life dr
frankenstein style yeah um
and if you know we'll cross that bridge
when we get there yeah i'll put together
a narrative about like you know what
you gotta you gotta stick to your guns i
let the haters get in my head
i let them convince me that i i wasn't
actually
a beautiful genius but indeed i am so
we'll go back yeah um all right so i
think that does it for
our first episode back um this new
format where we have these very very
concise tiny segments that that are very
short and don't go for like literally an
hour yeah
we're just we're just
absolute failures can we acknowledge
that
every time we make a change to the show
we're like oh this is going to be
shorter and it's going to be fantastic
and it just gets longer
well
so in
in your defense
you had a lot of information to cover
i didn't
i i think i still ran like 45 minutes so
oh god i'm looking at the timer it's two
and a half hours yeah you you you get a
pass on this one i i don't think i do
all right um well
the good news is i think it was good
content
i think it was i had fun yeah um so
hopefully at least three or four people
find it to be useful and are willing to
go through
this monster of an episode but um
it's great to be back thanks so much for
joining us on this new
season of the stronger by science
podcast like i said if you're interested
in that reverse dieting article it will
be published probably by the time this
this podcast goes live check the show
notes for the link if you're thinking
would it have been quicker for eric to
just read the article word for word
uh rather than present a segment on it
actually no it's a long article uh you
should check it out there's some extra
detail in there and a ton of references
so yes uh spoken word is about a hundred
words per minute at least for for
english speakers um
speaking of like a normal speaking
cadence the article is close to 15 000
words long so
just reading the article aloud would
have taken
about two and a half hours
uh and then you you gotta attack some
extra on that for like explaining
figures and characters yeah the people
who are just listening so even if that
one segment ran us about an hour and a
half here
you're still saving
it's it's still a net time saving over
just reading the article aloud well
there you go that's what we do here we
just aim to save everyone time
and give the most concise bits of
information necessary um but yeah once
again thanks so much for joining us on
this new season uh we are going to have
a little reshuffling in the publishing
uh
uh schedule but we're recording every
week things are going to be trickling
onto the youtube channel and all of our
podcast feeds in the weeks that follow
so we will be back very soon
thank you for listening to the stronger
by science podcast
if you enjoyed the podcast be sure to
sign up for our free newsletter to get
concise breakdowns of relevant research
as well as 28 free training programs for
all skill levels and all schedules
we hate spam just as much as you do so
we'll only email you when we have
something really interesting to share
with you
you can sign up for the free newsletter
at strongerbyscience.com
newsletter or just go to the stronger by
science homepage and click the free
programs button at the top
if you want to join in on the stronger
by science podcast conversation be sure
to check out our facebook group and our
subreddit the links for both are
provided in the description of today's
episode
finally please remember that we are not
medical doctors or registered dietitians
so before you make any changes to your
exercise or nutrition habits be sure to
check with a qualified health care
professional
once again thank you for listening and
we will be back soon with another
episode of the stronger by science
podcast
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
do
[Music]
you